Ja, auch immer. Wollen wir anfangen?
Gibt einen Directors Cut von Amadeus im Blu-ray.
Nur auf Blu-ray? Da lacht er.
Den will ich sehen. Wave ist das YouTube des Mehlzeitalters? Nein.
Wir können uns gleich nochmal über YouTube unterhalten. Wir können uns auch gerne über YouTube unterhalten, wir haben ja sonst nichts zu tun.
Ich bin jetzt sowieso dem Untergang geweiht. Ja, weil Clique de Flash dich jetzt übernimmt.
Die Zuhörer, die beschweren sich jetzt schon, dass wenn wir über Wave reden, dass sie dann abschalten, weil sie das alle nicht haben.
Wir haben alle Wave. Alle haben wir Wave. Ihr etwa nicht?
Wenn ich jetzt so lange warten würde, bis auf den letzten Edge Wave hat. Außerdem haben wir schon mal über Wave geredet, da hatte noch keiner Wave, weil ich das mal kurz erwähnen darf.
Das stimmt. Ja, da hatten wir auch selber noch keinen Wave.
Deswegen müssen wir jetzt eigentlich auch diese ganze Geschichte noch überhaupt nicht bringen. Und ich glaube, auch die Leute, die gerade Wave haben, haben nicht unbedingt…
Ja, wir haben alle keinen Wave.
Wir haben doch auch keinen Wave. Leute, Hauptsache, ihr seid alle auf unserer Wellenlänge. Hier ist Mobile Max, Ausgabe Nummer 35. Ich stelle vor, das Team zu meiner Rechten lächelnd, gut gelaunt.
Max, ich bin total begeistert von dieser Einleitung. Ich hab's jetzt schon wieder vergessen, aber die war großartig. Von Wave auf…
Das ist das Einzige, was du bemerken musst. Auf meiner linken Seite, ich begrüße Dennis. Hallo, Dennis.
Hallöchen.
Begrüßen ist toll.
Begrüßen ist super.
Wir sollten heute auch eigentlich einen sagenhaften Pegel auf dem Stream haben. Ich hab hier extra noch mal ein bisschen geschraubt und gefummelt.
Und wenn du rechts bist und ich links bin, dann müsste Tim ja in der Mitte sein, ne?
So ist es.
Dann lassen wir den Tim.
Ich sitze immer zwischen den…
Hallo, Tim. Hallo. Sind alle Wellen synchronisiert?
Ich finde es schön, dass wir uns immer so glücklich treffen.
Hier wieder aus dem Hauptstadtstudio.
Dennis macht es zwar immer ganz spannend, indem er sich einfach in den 24 Stunden vorher über keinerlei Kanal irgendwie kontaktieren lässt, auf keine Pings durch irgendwie auch…
Mich? Ich habe reagiert heute auf dein Dings. Du hast eine Stunde lang nicht geantwortet.
Wirklich? Du hast geantwortet, aber ich muss dir mal meinen Rechner runterfahren. Denn ich hatte ja heute… Ja, also vor zwei Tagen ist wirklich meine Büchse mal wieder so richtig schön in den Schlamm gefahren.
Sag mal, hast du mir nicht noch vor zwei Wochen erzählt, wie schlimm das ist, dass ich keinen habe und wie um Gottes Willen ich ohne Clean&Store Snow Leopard installiert habe?
Na du hattest ein Montagsgerät, ich hatte ein Dienstagsgerät. Eine Dienstagsinstallation. Nee, es hat sich hier… also wenn ich dir sagen könnte woran es liegt, keine Ahnung. Ich kann dir aber heute sagen, was ich getan habe, um den Effekt wieder loszuwerden.
Dein System ist doch mittlerweile aus Traditionsscheiße, oder?
Würde ich jetzt so nicht unterschreiben. Nein, ich glaube ich auch mal in meinen Panda-Settings ein bisschen reden, das klingt ja hier alles ein bisschen aus dem Topf. Soll ich mal erzählen? Also, mein System ist einfach… Du musst mehr so tun, als ob du uns… Leute, hallo! Es ist wirklich in den Schlamm gefahren. Das heißt, irgendwie fing es damit an, dass Programme, also es gab mehrere Effekte, dass Programme sich nicht mehr beenden lassen wollten. Wenn eins angefangen hat, dann fing auch randommäßig irgendwelche anderen an. Also es war vollkommen offensichtlich, dass in diesem System durch irgendetwas Diffuses immer so Kettenreaktionen ausgelöst wurden, die sich dann einfach in so Schlammpfuhleffekten…
Wie machst du das immer?
Naja, ich konnte es dann nach zwei Tagen irgendwie tracen da drauf, dass wenn ich diesen Mixer, der hier neben mir steht, der jetzt zwar noch nicht in Betrieb ist, aber immerhin Firewire hat und angeschlossen wird, so ein Phonik-Teil, wenn ich den ausgewählt habe oder wenn ein Programm versucht hat, den zu öffnen, also das Soundinterface, dann war einfach Schicht im Schacht, dann hing irgendwie alles. Habst du einen speziellen Treiber für ihn? Nein. Core Audio Standard. Was schon mal besonders zur Verwirrung beitrug, weil wenn man jetzt auf irgendwas so setzen würde, dann doch eher sozusagen auf die Treiber, die eben mit dem System kommen.
Ist dein Rechner 64-bit oder ohne?
Ohne.
Also, du meinst 64-bit Körner? 64-bit Prozessor? Core 2. Und läuft aber nun natürlich nur mit einem 32-bit Körner und so weiter, wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, es war schlimm und schon seit längerer Zeit habe ich auch so eine Verlangsamung festgestellt. Das heißt, dieser Effekt mit diesem Firewire-Treiber, das dann alles irgendwie kolossal gegen die Wand fuhr, das war dann eigentlich nur so das Ende von einem so langsamen Abgesang. Und es war eigentlich so dieses typische Verfetten, was man auch irgendwie kennt, wo ich auch sagen muss, wo sich irgendwie dann auch der Mac und Windows und der ganze andere Scheiß auch irgendwie nix nehmen. Dann schon lieber so ein richtig kristallines, metallisches FreeBSD.
Meinst du, das verfettet nicht?
Verfettet auch? Also auch bei FreeBSD ab und zu mal Cleaning Store.
Ja, also das ist eigentlich das Beurteil hier, dass Computer einfach nicht in der Lage sind, so ihre Systemintegrität auch mal wirklich zu garantieren. Also das ist, wenn es irgendwie einmal läuft, dass es dann auch immer läuft.
Na gut, vielleicht...
Ja, an den musste ich nämlich auch gerade denken. Ich hatte da irgendwie so eine Büchse, die habe ich nie angefasst. Die lief halt so ein uraltes FreeBSD 2-Punkt irgendwas. Und der lief. Und der war auch noch auf so einem uralten Celeron-Prozessor war der irgendwie auch nach diesen 10 Jahren so scheiße snappy und responsiv. Also da rannte einfach das Terminal in einer Geschwindigkeit, wie ich das auch auf Macintosh 5-6 Jahre später einfach nicht kennengelernt habe.
Ist das nicht diese alte Witz von Otto, wenn sie es wirklich sauber halten wollen, nicht betreten?
Ja, seitdem ich rausnehme ist meine Wohnung wirklich rein.
Ja, das schnell Macbolt einfach nicht benutzen.
Genau, Rechner nicht benutzen und so macht Dennis das ja. Deswegen hat Dennis immer so einen performanten Rechner.
Der installiert alle zwei Wochen einen 966-Emulator.
Ich bin halt schlauer als du, ich mach bei jeder Major-Release einen Clean&Store.
Ja gut, schlauer ist das eine, die Zeit dafür haben, ist das andere.
Hey, aber Leute hier in Clean&Store investieren, später sparen.
Ja gut, jetzt hatte ich aber genau wieder dieses Problem. Also als das irgendwie so war und ich hab dann hier noch ein anderes MacBook mir gerade kurz noch ausgeliehen und hab halt gegen getestet und es lag einfach mal nicht an diesem Kabel und es lag nicht an diesem Bus und es lag auch nicht an diesem Device, es ist einfach alles problemlos funktioniert. Es lag an meinem System und dann dachte ich mir Clean&Store und dann fiel mir ein, der Clean&Store ist gestieft worden. Es gibt keinen Clean&Store mehr bei Snow Leopard, es gibt einfach nur einen installiert, du Sau! Und dann darfst du dann noch so ein bisschen sagen, welche Druckertreiber du alle nicht haben willst und welche Sprachen so, dass du deinen Computer nicht auf Koreanisch benutzt und das war's. Ah ja, du kannst noch XL wegschmeißen, aber das bringt ja alles nichts.
Gibt's Arcade install noch?
Nein.
Ach, gar nicht.
Denn es gibt diese Auswahl von diesen drei Sachen, Iris install und dann dieses irgendwie neues Ding mit irgendwie übernehmen, gibt es so nicht. Das heißt, du kannst auf einer Platte, wo schon ein System drauf ist, ihm nicht sagen, dass er das System als solches komplett ignorieren soll und durch ein anderes ersetzen soll. Das fand ich dann erstmal ein bisschen...
Na, du könntest es auch wahrscheinlich über ein Trick-In kriegen, oder? So Späßchen wie oben das Festplatten-Dienstprogramm starten, platte formatieren und dann...
Ja, ich will aber nicht meine Platte formatieren, da sind 300 GB Daten drauf, die will ich nicht wegschmeißen. Hier geht es nur um den System und Library und alles, was in irgendeiner Form betroffen ist und das hat ja der alte, neue System installieren und das alte beibehalten. Also er hat ja dann dieses alte System in previous Ordner, previous System Ordner geschmissen. Oh, ich bin schon ein bisschen angemüdet. Angemüdet? Ja und das gab es irgendwie alles nicht mehr. Dann stand ich da und hab ein bisschen nachgedacht. Wenn du im Netz suchst nach CleanInstall und Snowlappert, dann komm halt nur diese, naja, da musst du halt irgendwie erst die Platte löschen und dann klar, ich meine natürlich, aber ich wollte meine Platte nicht löschen. Weil, dann hab ich drüber nachgedacht, was in aller Welt in Apple gefahren ist. Wenn ich mir meine Erfahrungen mit den anderen Fresh Installs so anschaue, dann muss ich auch sagen, das war auch sehr halbseiten. Weil wenn man das nämlich gemacht hat, was war denn so ein Fresh Install überhaupt?
Was passiert da denn?
Na, er hat den alten Systemordner komplett ignoriert und einen neuen installiert.
Also quasi ein Archive Install, das meinst du?
Ja, so hieß es.
Ah, okay. Das habt ihr als Clean Install bezeichnet.
Und dann kannst du noch die Netzwerks-Setting und die User-Settings übernehmen.
Also das User-Verzeichner sozusagen.
Genau, sodass du dann sozusagen auch mit dem neuen System gleich deinen Users, dich einloggen kannst, deine Prefs hast und so weiter.
Ach, das habt ihr als Clean Install bezeichnet.
Was dann aber wegfällt, war verschiedene Sachen. Sachen, die dann so in Library installiert waren. Irgendwie so dein Adobe Photoshop und so weiter.
Die konntest du dann aber nach und nach überschieben einfach.
Ja, aber das musstest du dann halt aber auch erstmal tun. Und dann musst du auch erstmal wissen, was du tust. Und das ist so einfach nicht. Und Treiber dementsprechend fielen halt auch komplett raus. Das war eigentlich auch das, was ich wollte. Ich wollte auch eigentlich nur die Treiber loswerden. Ich sah schon das Problem mit irgendwie, naja, da kommt wieder das ganze Adobe-Rot und andere Sachen, die so mit Library sich da irgendwie zu so einem Geheimbund zusammengeschlossen haben. Ich dachte mir nur so, egal, die zwei Stunden, die investierst du. Hauptsache, du hast wieder ein funktionierendes System. Also schön war das eigentlich nicht. Es war nur besser als alles, was es auch davor gab. Wenn wir jetzt mal so die früheren Situationen machen, weil ganz früher gab es wirklich nur dieses komplett neu so und wie komplett neu?
Nö.
Naja, gut, bei macOS hast du halt einfach den Systemordner genommen und kannst durch die Gegend fliegen. Das war super, oder? Ja, aber bei macOS 10 war es schon sehr schwierig.
Du musst vor allem mehrere haben und dann switchen.
Ja, und dann hast du noch irgendwie Ports installiert, so und slash opt und diese ganzen Sachen. Also du hast dann eine ganze Menge Interdependenzen. So, naja, wie auch immer. Dann stand ich also da und hatte irgendwie überlegt, wie sie das machen. Dann dachte ich mir so, naja klar, man kann ja irgendwie auf so ein neues System dann auch installieren und von Time-Machine sich das runterholen. Wenn man sozusagen einen Time-Machine-Backup hat, dann kann man das da beim Installieren irgendwie holen.
Ach, das bezeichnet ihr als Clean-Install, oder? Hab ich auch schon hundertmal einen Clean-Install gemacht.
Nee, nee, das bezeichne ich nicht als Clean-Install. Das bezeichne ich als, installierst du ein komplett neues System, lösch die ganze Platte und ziehst dann alle deine Daten vom Backup runter. Dieser Archive-Install hat ja deine Daten auf der Platte belassen.
Jaja, nee, es gab dieses Archive-Install, das habe ich ein paar Mal gemacht. Und ich habe auch dieses Time Machine Backup gemacht, gezwungenermaßen, als meine Platte nämlich mal ein Problem hatte.
Dann habe ich aber nicht gleich mit angefangen, allein schon deshalb, weil ich hier sitze, das ganze Zeit über WLAN machen müssen und irgendwie 300 Kilo Arbeit, WLAN und so weiter, das hätte ewig gedauert. Das wollte ich eigentlich nicht tun, trotzdem habe ich es mal angetestet, weil der Partner wäre ja dann dieser Migrationsassistent. Den habe ich dann mal gestartet und mal geguckt, was er mir so anbietet. Und er bietet mir dann auch Time Machine Recovery an. Und was hat er mir angeboten? Er hat mir den Shared-Ordner auf meiner Time Capsule angeboten. Er hat mir die externen angeschlossenen Platten, mein Drobo, angeboten. Aber er hat nicht meinen User-Bereich auf der Time Capsule. Du kannst ja den User einrichten.
Okay, das ist aber ein bisschen...
Na so, wir sind zwei Leute in unserem Haushalt und jeder hat seinen eigenen Bereich. Und jeder hat in seinem eigenen Bereich seinen Maker.
Ja, aber das ist etwas, das finde ich...
Genau, ich weiß nicht, ob das dann nicht, wenn ich jetzt wirklich installiert hätte und dieser eingebaute Migrationsassistent, ob es sich da nicht anders dargestellt hätte. Kann ich nicht sicher sagen. Allerdings habe ich davon Abstand genommen. Was habe ich dann gemacht? Ich habe eine Platte genommen und habe extern das System komplett frisch neu installiert. Also Snow Leopard CD und habe dann irgendwie auf eine leere Platte das drauf installiert. Soweit alles nicht besonders exciting, ich weiß. Ihr fragt euch sowieso schon, warum ich es soweit aushole. Dann war diese Installation zu Ende. Und dann kam so eine Art Migrationsassistent hoch. Es war aber nicht der Migrationsassistent, sondern es war das, was in dem Installer mit drin ist. Und ich habe jetzt leider keinen Screenshot gemacht, aber da war erstmal eine deutlich erhöhtere Auswahl von Items, also Kategorien von Items, die man so übernehmen kann. Also unter anderem die User, die Netzwerksettings, aber dann war dann auch so Machine-Info und so. Da habe ich irgendwie alles mal Ja gesagt. Das war mir irgendwie alles ein bisschen unklar. Das heißt, ich habe auf die externe Platte installiert und habe dann von meiner internen Platte die ganzen Daten übernommen.
Und wie willst du es später wieder zurückkriegen?
Mit dem Migrationssystem?
Das kann ich mir jetzt einfach mit dem Carbon Copy-Kloner direkt auf die Platte klonen.
Und dem traust du?
Dem traue ich.
Carbon Copy-Kloner habe ich auch schon mehrfach gemacht. Das funktioniert einwandfrei.
Also Carbon Copy-Kloner, der funktioniert einwandfrei, weil das ist nichts anderes als eine GUI für die Standard, wie heißt das?
Dito.
Dito, genau. Für Dito. Was das seit Ewigkeiten bei Mac OS X mitgelieferte Ich-kopiere-Dateien-auf-HFS-Hin-&-Hair-Tool ist.
Carbon Copy-Kloner ist auch so, wenn man mal defragmentieren will und sehr, sehr viel Zeit hat, ist das auch durchaus ein Tool der Wahl.
Ja, also das ist wirklich extrem rock solide, hab noch nie Stress gehabt mit Carbon Copy-Kloner. Man kann es auch mit Disk Utility machen. Das ist jetzt nicht so der Punkt.
Mit Restore und Dinks und so, ja?
Also du kannst im Wesentlichen die Daten einfach rüber schieben, wenn die Platten halbwegs groß sind, dass gleich groß sind. Sorry, jetzt kommt eine Nachfrage.
Du hast es auf der Platte installiert per Migrationsassistent. Auf der externen Platte? Also zuerst Clean Install und dann Platten.
Nein, nein, ich habe einfach den Standard Installer genommen. Hab das System installiert nach meinen Wünschen. Koreanisch und so weiter hab ich weggelassen. Auf der externen leeren Platte. Und dann war er fertig und dann hat er gesagt, möchtest du vielleicht noch Daten übernehmen.
Genau, okay.
Ohne, dass er sich jetzt schon komplett ins neue System gebootet hätte. Und da war dann die Auswahl sehr viel größer und anders als beim normalen Migration-Assistent Punkt ab. Es war irgendwie anders. Du musst jetzt nochmal starten und mal angucken und Screenshot machen. Es war irgendwie in dem Moment mehr als ich erwartet hatte, aber ich wollte schnell vorankommen. Hab dann irgendwie alles ausgewählt, weil das klang mir irgendwie alles plausibel. Und dann war er dann irgendwie am Rattern und hat nochmal meine 250 GB Daten hinterhergeholt. Und dann buddete das Ding neu. Und ich bin ein bisschen aus den Wolken gefallen.
Low and behold heißt es dann immer, ne?
Danach funktionierte alles. Alles war so, wie ich es haben wollte. Also es war alles da. User und so weiter. Gut, das hat mich nicht weiter überrascht. Aber was mich überrascht hat ist, dass diese Migration auch die Treiber rübergeholt hat. Das heißt, er hat auch aus dem alten System die ganzen Treiber alles mit übernommen. Und installiert und meines Wissens macht der normale Migrationsassistent sowas nicht.
Und Port und sowas hat er auch mitgep-
Alles.
Alles?
Nichts fehlt. Ist ja fast schon.
Vielleicht hat er festgestellt, dass das sein Rechner war.
Und danach lief es einfach flüssig. Wo ich also vorher irgendwie im Morast gestampft bin, lief es einfach total flüssig. Also wer Zicken hat mit seinem Snorlebart und wo auch, sagen wir mal, so mehrere Upgrades in Folge irgendwie einem das Gefühl geben, es könnte auch alles ein bisschen schneller gehen und so kann das ja wohl nicht gedacht sein, könnte das ein Weg sein, mit dem man sich ein bisschen freischaufelt? Jetzt ist hier einfach alles top.
Also ich bin mit meinem Problem ein bisschen weiter auf der Spur und sieht so aus, als ob das nicht mit einem Clean-Install zu machen wäre oder sonst was, sondern ich habe ein EFI-Problem, wie ich rausgekriegt habe. Und zwar das MacBook EFI 1.7 hat Probleme mit meiner Festplatte, mit der Western Digital.
Was ist so ein Ding? 1.7?
E-F-I.
Dein BIOS sozusagen. The system formerly known as BIOS.
Und da klagen und Open Bootstrap, oder wie ist das ganz früher mal bei PowerPC? Open Firmware, genau. Da klagen bei Apple in den Foren einige drüber, in den Diskussionsforen. Und ich habe das schon auf Leopard ein bisschen mitbekommen, da war es allerdings noch nicht so tragisch. Da passierte das irgendwie seltener. Und jetzt passiert das relativ häufig mal. Die Maschine friert ein für eine gewisse Zeit lang. Und passiert wohl mit SATA-zweifähigen Platten. Nein, es gibt den Fix für diese Platte, die Apple irgendwie mal verbaut hat. Die Geräusche gemacht hat. Das ist ja was anderes. Meine Platte macht ja keine Geräusche.
Und da war doch mal was, wo du erzählt hast, dass die SATA 2, dass die gar keinen SATA 2 unterstützen. Und dann kam doch ein neues EFI-Dings raus, dass die jetzt auch SATA 2 unterstützen. Gleichzeitig aber sagen, dass es nicht supported ist. War doch nicht mal was. Da hast du doch erzählt. Da warst du doch sehr enttäuscht, dass irgendwie alle Platten nur SATA 1 sind.
Mich interessiert nicht, die Bohne auf was SATA 1, was SATA 2 ist.
Du meinst diese Performance-Geschichte vom SATA-Bus? Ob das jemand wirklich gebraucht hat, weiß ich nicht. War das das, wovon du jetzt geredet hast? Ging es dir um Performance? Nein.
Nein, es ist wirklich, es hängt einfach. Das gesamte System hängt.
Wenn du was tust?
An diversen Schilden. Jemand anderes behauptet hier, dass es mit Little Snitch Probleme gibt.
Das System bleibt stehen?
Es bleibt stehen. Ich kriege einen Beachball in quasi einem Programm. Das geht so eine Weile nach durch. Und dann hat man das Gefühl, als würde die Platte stehen bleiben zwischendurch. Und er würde nichts mehr machen. Und man kriegt das auch mit, sobald wir probieren, irgendwie schreibend oder lesend auf die Platte zuzugreifen. Adium gerne mal, wenn es irgendwie einen Sound abspielen will oder sowas in der Richtung. Und dann irgendwann kriegt er sich wieder ein. Das ist alles wieder wie vorher.
Was heißt irgendwann?
20 bis 30 Sekunden. Vielleicht mal eine Minute. Schon so, dass es in Stresssituationen sehr, sehr nervig ist. Und das nervt ein bisschen. Das Mittels Little Snitch wäre ich vielleicht auch nochmal ausprobieren.
Ja, Little Snitch ist das einzige, was nach meinem Clean Install nicht so funktioniert hat wie vorher. Der hat sich sozusagen von dieser Übernahme der Daten nicht beeindrucken lassen. Der muss seine Datenbank, wie er sich den verhält, an einer Stelle ablegen, die nicht zurückmigriert wird. Da muss ich jetzt alle Settings wieder neu machen. Was ein bisschen anstrengend ist. Ansonsten ist der kleine Vogel ja sehr hilfreich. Wer Little Snitch nicht kennt, sollte man ja vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen, das ist dieses schicke Tool von Objective Development aus Österreich, obdev.at, die auch das geile Launchbar machen. Das ist quasi eine Outbound Firewall. Damit kann man eben Programme, die nach Hause telefonieren, sehr genau beschränken, mit wem sie worüber kommunizieren dürfen.
Personal Firewall heißt das auch, oder?
Ja, das ist sehr hilfreich bei geschwätzigen Programmen, die sich zu sehr mit irgendwelchen Hinterzimmern absprechen wollen.
Aber man sollte auf jeden Fall eine Version, die auch unter Snow Lab läuft, runterladen.
Das ist dann die aktuelle 2.2.
Genau, weil die davor macht so ein bisschen Trouble.
Ja, wie das immer so ist, wenn die Körner sich ändern. Tja, ich hab mir jetzt schon so einiges notiert hier. Wollen wir mal die Sachen mit den iPods einsacken? Da haben wir das hinter uns. Nachdem wir jetzt so eine lange Pause gemacht hatten und letztes Mal uns ausschließlich über Wissen schon unterhalten haben.
Kann man die noch als neu bezeichnen, die iPods? Eigentlich jetzt nach so langer Zeit.
Nö, aber wir können über die aktuellen iPods reden.
Die noch aktuellen iPods.
Ja, genau. Und dann halt auch dieses ganze iTunes 9 Geschubse.
Also an den iPods gibt es doch im Wesentlichen zu sagen, dass sie keine Kamera haben, oder? Also dass der iPod Touch keine Kamera hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das das Wesentliche ist, was man sagen kann. Also ich hab ja da so einen geheimen Favoriten.
Wie einen geheimen Favoriten?
Naja, es gibt da, also ich finde das Lineup ja ganz geil. Ich muss jetzt eigentlich gerade mal zur Auffrischung, und dass ich hier keine Scheiße erzähle, mir mal so das aktuelle Lineup nochmal vor Augen führen.
Ich geh mal auf www.apple.com, ja.
Also der neue iPod Touch ist in gewisser Hinsicht konsequent. Ich meine, mittlerweile hat sich herausgestellt, dass sie sehr wohl eine Kamera geplant haben für den Touch. Sie sagen zwar, dass sie sich aus Marketinggründen dagegen...
Als ein Spielegerät sei und ein Spielegerät keine Kamera hat. Was kann ich jetzt nicht sehen? Ich tippe mir mit dem Finger an die Stirn und sage, die sind ja doof und tun nur so als ob.
Meine Gerüchteküche hat gesagt, sie hatten einfach ein Problem mit dem Bauten der Kameras.
Es gibt auch einiges, was darauf hindeutet.
Wo wollten sie dann ein Problem haben?
Der ist ja schon zerlegt worden.
Die waren wohl irgendwie nicht okay.
Aber im iPhone haben sie ja auch welche.
Ja, aber das iPhone ist deutlich dicker als der iPod Touch.
Richtig, der iPod Touch ist viel dünner. Da fehlt ihnen einfach der Platz. Das war wahrscheinlich eine andere Kamera und die hat dann wohl im letzten Moment einfach ihren Quality Assurance Test nicht bestanden. Da haben sie gesagt, scheiß drauf. Kann natürlich auch sein, dass sie gesagt haben, was hat Geier? Ich meine, sie haben wahrscheinlich eine ganze Batterie von Dingen, die stimmen müssen. Technisch muss das natürlich funktionieren und so weiter und der Preis muss stimmen. Weiß der Geier, welche Zahl in den roten Bereich geraten ist in dem Moment? Andererseits ist es halt so, dass sie eben den iPod Touch derzeit als Gaming-Maschine Featuren und von daher ist die Kamera nicht unbedingt das Wichtigste. Wird wahrscheinlich kommen. Also ich wäre noch nicht mehr überrascht, wenn sie das noch binnen eines Jahres ändern.
Also ich würde sagen, es ändern sie relativ flott. Also es sieht ja alles so aus, als ob Platz dafür vorgesehen wäre. Da steckt nur ein bisschen Plastik drin an einer Stelle.
Richtig.
Und wo eine Kamera sehr gut reinpassen würde, wo sie auch hinpassen würde, packt man auch eine Kamera rein, sobald sie...
Na gut, aber das eigentlich Interessante ist natürlich, dass sie das getan haben, was ja auch zu erwarten war, dass sie auf die neue Prozessor-Generation gegangen sind, wie eben bei dem iPhone 3GS und dass das Ding halt einfach mal... Rattenschnell. Sie haben das irgendwie mit der Grafik nochmal deutlich beschleunigt. Und das hat natürlich... Das wird wahrscheinlich auch ausreichen. Weil das Ding verkauft sich irgendwie ganz gut. Und vor allem, sie haben ja den Preis gesenkt. Du kriegst ja irgendwie jetzt den alten quasi für 200 Dollar. Und das ist schon... Na ja, attraktiv.
Ein schönes Spielgerät.
Also für Leute, für die jetzt, sagen wir mal, dieser Performance-Aspekt nicht so wichtig ist. Die also mit den Spielen, so wie sie eben auf der alten Generation auch schon liefen, zufrieden sind. Die kriegen halt jetzt für 200 Dollar so einen Teil. Und ich glaube, die nächste Generation geht dann bei 300 los.
Wobei, ich muss sagen, das ist, ich find ja, ich hätt's nicht gedacht, dass das 3GS wirklich so viel schneller ist. Aber es ist ja im Alltag unglaublich viel schneller. Du dürftest mittlerweile auch die Erfahrung gemacht haben, oder?
Ja, jetzt könnte ich mich da tatsächlich mal zu qualifiziert äußern.
Also ich hab neulich mal wieder das iPhone 3G, eines Kumpels in der Hand gehabt und hab da mal eine URL eingetippt. Das Tippen ist so viel langsamer auf dem etwas älteren Gerät. Das ist unglaublich.
Das ist wirklich interessant. Es gibt ja so eine nominelle Geschwindigkeitssteigerung, die irgendwo so bei zwischen 50% und 100% liegt. Aber ich hab das Gefühl, dass auf diesem Prozessor bestimmte Dinge so optimiert sind, die sich einfach in den kritischen Stellen, wo das Alte extrem gehakt hat, so erfreulich bemerkbar machen, dass man das Gerät gar nicht wiedererkennt. Also ich würde sagen, gefühlt ist das Ding 5-mal so schnell. Was diese Response-Zeit betrifft.
Es gibt Anwendungen, die erst jetzt Sinn machen.
Vielleicht haben sie ja mit.
Ja, alles macht jetzt überhaupt erst Sinn.
Das ganze Gerät, vorher war ich gar keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist eben auch meine Überlegung, dass sie mit dem neuen Prozessor Optimierungen fahren können, die der alte Prozessor so nicht ermöglicht hat. Dass sie also einfach den Code auch besser targeten können. Mit ihrem neuen Compiler, mit ihrem geilen LLVM, über den wir heute noch sprechen werden. Also das ist eine reine Vermutung. Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären, dass es so flüssig ist.
Also ich vermute mal, dass der RAM extrem wichtig ist. Dass er so viel mit dem RAM haben.
Das stimmt, RAM spielt auf jeden Fall auch eine Rolle. Das ist richtig.
Und das kriegt man ja gerade bei Safari mit. Also bei Safari ist es ja, wenn man das vorher in den Hintergrund geschaltet hat, irgendeine andere Applikation gestartet hat, Safari wieder gestartet hat, war die Chance, dass die Seite neu geladen werden musste, relativ hoch. Jetzt wird es einfach in RAM gehalten und fertig ist die Laube. RAM, RAM, RAM, RAM.
Aber mein eigentlicher Favorit in diesem neuen Lineup ist ja der Nano. Da muss ich ja sagen, da haben sie ja wirklich was gerissen. Also das ist ja nun wirklich der Brüller. Ist euch das überhaupt klar geworden, wie viel toller der iPod Nano im Vergleich zu dem alten ist?
Weil er jetzt ein Radio hat?
Nein. Unter anderem auch, weil er ein Radio hat. Also Radio finde ich alles neu. Das Ding hat einen größeren Bildschirm. Das Ding hat ein Radio eingebaut. Und jetzt weiß ich auch, warum es so lange gedauert hat, bis Apple ein Radio einbaut. Wir bauen es halt erst dann ein, wenn sie das quasi als Befruchtungsmaschine für ihren iTunes-Store verwenden können.
Wie, wie, wie?
Na du hörst jetzt Musik über iTunes, äh, über Radio. Und das Gerät detectet, was es ist. Und schickt dich gleich in den iTunes-Store zum Kauf.
Ach nee, das hab ich nicht gesehen. Ich hab das Gerät nie angeguckt irgendwo.
Ich hab's mir auch noch nie angeschaut. Das heißt, die Shazam haben so lange ihre DB aufgebaut, bis sie den Service dann an Apple verticken konnten.
Keine Ahnung, auf welche Datenbank sie da setzen. Sie nennen es iTunes-Tagging. Und sie haben auch eine Pause. Sie haben irgendeinen Buffer drin. Du kannst irgendwie, das weiß ich gerade nicht genau wie lange, also eine signifikante Zeit kannst du sozusagen pausieren. Und dann schreibt er einfach Radio in den Rahmen und kannst halt weitermachen, so wie ITV das mit Fernsehen macht. Naja, dann haben sie einen Pedometer drin.
Der so mittelfunktionieren soll, aber okay.
Das weiß ich nicht, wie gut der funktioniert, aber dieses ganze Walking, also das ist einfach das Jogger-Teil. Es ist einfach das Ding, was du dabei haben willst, wenn du joggst, wenn du nicht einen Shuffle hast. Also Shuffle würde ich sagen, ist so der reine, pure Jogger. Das ist derjenige, der nicht mehr interagieren will und so weiter. Und wenn du halt ein bisschen verrückter drauf bist und auch mal ein Foto schießen willst und so weiter, bzw. in dem Fall geht es nicht um Foto, sondern eben um Video. Also wenn du irgendwie andere Dinge machen willst, wenn du auswählen willst, dann ist eben der Nano das Modell.
Also ich trauere ja immer noch ein bisschen meinem, also der aktuelle und das vorgängige Modell kommt schon wieder ran. Ich hatte den iPod Nano der zweiten Generation, natürlich in Schwarz. Und das war mein Lieblings-iPod überhaupt. Dem trauere ich bis heute ein bisschen nach. iPod Nano der zweiten Generation.
Auch der Hochkant.
Der Hochkant, der aber nicht. Der erste war ja so super glossy und es zerkratzt ohne Ende und hinten Metall.
Den fanden alle total schick.
Da kam der so komisch breit raus, der so flach war, als wenn einer drauf gelobt hätte.
Der zweite war erstmal der, der war auch so hoch wie der erste. Und wie auch die aktuellen Modelle, aber so abgerundet und außen so eher raues Aluminium. Dann kam dieser kleine Fatty, genau, den du beschrieben hast.
Den keiner mochte, oder?
Den keiner mochte. Und dann haben sie jetzt quasi wieder das Hochformat genommen. Und jetzt nochmal Hochformat. Und ich hatte quasi den zweiten. Und der war, eigentlich war es der geilste iPad, den ich jemals hatte, weil erstens war es eine reine Musikmaschine.
Keine Videos.
Keine Videos, kein Schnick-Schnack, kein irgendwas. Der Akku hat beliebig lange gehalten. Also ich musste nie, ich musste wirklich nie.
Ich konnte mal mit meinem Rad einstellen, drei Tage, zehn Tage. Beliebig.
Unendlich. Also ich hatte wirklich nie das Problem, dass ich den laden musste. Also wie ich es beim anderen iPod hatte, dass man hin und wieder musste über Nacht laden. Sondern hin und wieder mal Musik drauf spielen und ein paar Podcast-Updaten. Hat den lang genug geladen, damit er wieder zwei Wochen durchhielt. Das war echt irre. Und ich hoffe, den neuen sind immer noch genauso gut.
Also du wolltest jetzt einfach nur sagen, dass du deinen alten iPod mochtest.
Mein Walkman damals hat zwei Stunden Musik gemacht und dann war vorbei.
Lass uns doch mal lieber über die aktuellen Geräte reden und nicht über das, was wir früher mal geil fanden.
Damals. Langsam kann man das alter.
Aber wir sind doch alte. Also damals war noch mal alles besser.
Aber wir müssen das doch nicht die ganze Zeit raushängen lassen, dass wir so alt sind.
Heute ist die DDR übrigens, wäre sie 60 Jahre alt geworden, wenn es sie noch gehen würde.
Es hören unter Umständen Jugendliche zu.
Du bist hier unser Quoten-Ossi, oder?
Genau, und ich bin hier der Quoten-Moderator, der einzige, der sich hier um Gesprächsführungen bemüht. Also, alles gesagt.
Und du bist eigentlich der Quoten-Nerd, der das ist.
Also, das Ding kann keine Fotos machen, aber Video. Das finde ich echt interessant.
Einer von uns muss noch die Quoten-Fraume tragen.
Nein.
Das ist ein Scheiß.
Weil die Kamera zu schlecht ist dafür. Weil die Kamera zu schlecht ist. Weil so eine dünne Kamera kann es noch nicht so gut machen.
Das Ding ist so um Miniatur, das ist einfach...
Aber Filme kann es.
Bei Filmen ist es nicht so entscheidend, dass es so total verwacht ist.
Aber auch die Qualität der Filme war schlechter als vom iPhone. Okay, es ist die gleiche Auflösung wie beim iPhone, aber es sieht auch so gut aus?
Nein.
Aber 640, ob es gut aussieht, keine Ahnung, wo würde jeder eine andere Meinung haben?
Wobei eigentlich ist es relativ okay. Ich hab so auf YouTube so ein paar Videos gesehen, die so Gizmodo und so hochgespielt haben, die waren schon echt okay. Also es war so, klar, es ist jetzt...
Das ist nicht high-end, es ist einfach in deinem fucking Musik-Fair mit drin. Aber es ist halt einfach da. Du hast es halt einfach dabei. Und das ist ja genau das, was Ovi zählt bei Video. Du hast es halt einfach dabei. Naja, ich fand das auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert, was sie da alles eingebaut haben. So, gibt's wirklich nicht mehr dazu zu erzählen? Doch. Es gibt iTunes 9. Ich hab jetzt gleich mal so eine ruhige Minute hinterher geworfen. So eine Pause.
Damit ich tippen kann.
Wisst ihr, was das einzig Gute ist an iTunes 9?
Dass iTunes 10 kommt?
Das ist meine Hoffnung. Also dieses iTunes 9 war wirklich dermaßen noch viel langsamer und schlechter als all das iTunes, was vorher mich schon irgendwie genervt hat und mir den Schlaf geraubt hat. Dass ich mir schon, also das fand ich schon wirklich frech, einem sowas vor die Nase zu knallen und dann irgendwie nur noch Features, die ich immer noch nicht genießen kann. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Also sie haben eine Sache wirklich verbessert bei iTunes 9 und das ist das Syncing. Das ist wirklich besser geworden. Und ich rede jetzt erstmal nicht von dem Syncing der Applikation. Also mit diesem Anordnen. Seid ihr eigentlich jetzt auf 3.1 auf euren Telefonen oder seid ihr alle wieder zurückmarschiert?
Geht ja nicht.
Dann kommst du ja nicht wieder zurück.
Wie, du kommst nicht zurück?
Dann kommst du nicht zurück. Nee, Apple erlaubt dir nicht, dass du ein altes OS installierst.
Wie?
iTunes fragt nach, vor der Installation, ist denn dieses OS noch aktuell?
Nein. Nein, die Schweine. Echt? Apple ist evil.
Und selbst wenn, würdest du es nicht schaffen, dein Bassband down zu grade. Das geht nämlich schon mal gar nicht.
Das war ja schon immer so mit dem nicht down.
Also mit gefangen mitgegangen. Das heißt, ihr seid jetzt auf 3.1.
Wir haben im Twitter gesagt, dass es geht. Die sind natürlich verflucht von uns.
Wir verfluchen euch, dass Tessering noch gehen würde. Ich wach mal uns auf. Nachlesen, wie es so ist mit 3.1. Ich hab ja gehört, dass Tessering nicht mehr geht. Bei Twitter so, ja Tessering geht. Irgendwelche Block-Einträge, ja Tessering kein Problem.
Keiner hat es ausprobiert. Alle haben nur gesehen, dass es mit 3.1.
Oh ja, jetzt hab ich es auch mal ausprobiert. Gerade war der Button noch da, jetzt ist er weg.
Während mein Update-Balken noch so hochging, dann so, nee geht doch nicht.
Hättet ihr mal auf mich gehört. Ich hab schon vorher gewarnt, ich hab noch 3.0.
Du hattest ja dein Telefon gar nicht zu der Zeit.
Na klar hatte ich ein iPhone. Mein Alte ist klar, aber macht ja nix. Gott sei Dank hab ich bei dem 3GS auch noch ein 3.0 drauf. Aber ich wusste es vorher, dass es kommen wird. Es hat sich einfach abgezeichnet, es war einfach so klar.
Aber ich hab doch ein Unlock, das verdammte Scheiße.
Das ist echt eine Unverschämtheit. Das Apple wirbt mit Tethering auch.
Sie haben sich da schon gut rausgeredet.
Wann, wo?
Sie werben mit Tethering bei Depends on a Provider. Das steht schon so noch als Zusatz dabei. Da musst du wirklich aufpassen.
Auch bei Apple IT?
Ich glaub schon, ja. Und wenn, dann unterstützen sie da ja auch nur die italienischen Provider. Das heißt, die italienischen Carrier Profiles, die da drauf sind, die werden das Tethering wahrscheinlich anhaben. Aber wenn der Italiener, so wie ich hier, der geborene Italiener, weißt du, wenn der hier kommt und nach Berlin, hat der da keine Tethering.
Ja, das ist total...
Das ist überhaupt das Ding, also in Europa, ich mein in den USA, wo man dieses Land eigentlich normalerweise nicht verlässt. Und gewohnt ist, wenn man außerhalb der USA sowieso in die Luft gesprengt zu werden, dann macht das ja irgendwie keinen großen Unterschied. Aber hier in Europa, wo du wie alle Nasen lang mal eine Grenze wechselst, da ist das doch einfach mal Störzbecker Deluxe.
Und weltweit ist ja das alles aufgehoben, also selbst in Kanada ist jetzt vorbei mit...
Nein, nein, das ist nur die Exklusivität ist weg.
Das heißt?
Dass auch andere Provider mit Apple einen Vertrag schließen dürfen, dass sie das iPhone verkaufen dürfen im gleichen Land.
Aber?
Das heißt nicht, dass irgendein Provider, der keinen Vertrag mit Apple hat, das verkaufen darf.
Naja, aber dann würden ja hier alle Provider natürlich sofort einen Vertrag mit Apple machen. Dann würde es entsprechende Profile kommen. Aber nee, da muss ich warten bis nächstes Jahr, weil die Telekom schon gesagt hat, auf jeden Fall die Influenzivität noch bis Ende des Jahres.
Naja, ich meine, gut. Was passiert jetzt, ne? Ich meine, O2 in Deutschland kann... Also ich glaube jetzt langsam, dass das nächste Jahr vorbei ist. Aber wenn man sich anhört, wie die Telekom rumeiert, mit sie werden auch noch über das Jahresende hinaus... Das ist ja eine geile Formulierung. Das heißt, mit dem nächsten iPhone werden auch andere Anbieter in Deutschland das iPhone füllen.
Ja, dann kommt noch Vodafone dazu.
Ja, und vielleicht auch O2.
Hier gibt es einen Hinweis, wie man mit alten iTunes doch noch ein Downgrade irgendwie hinbekommt.
Wollen wir noch über das Thema weiter reden? Ich bin schon wieder komplett aus der Spur. Also, blablabla, wir stellen fest, mit 3.1 wird Tethering nur noch möglich mit einem signierten Profil. Das Problem ist, dass wenn du jetzt im Ausland bist und quasi sowieso bei einem Provider unterkommst, der nicht deiner ist, weil den es da gar nicht gibt, du auch gar keine Möglichkeit hast, Tethering überhaupt noch zu verwenden. Selbst wenn es da billige Anbieter gäbe, die dir das gerne verkaufen wollen würden.
Das ist total der Scheiß, dass das so ist. Dafür zahle ich so viele Dollars, damit ich irgendwie anlockt habe und dann doch nicht.
Weißt du, was die Lösung für das Problem ist?
Ja, es stinkt auch. Ich will keinen Jailbreak. Ich nimm mich mit runtergelassenen Hosen durch die Gegend.
Das wär aber das erste Mal, wo ich einen Grund für Jailbreak muss sagen.
Also ich fand ja, ich fand ja schon vorher, also es gibt keinen zwingenden Grund für einen Jailbreak. Ich fand aber vorher gab es schon so, zum Beispiel, dass unter der alten Firmware, also dass das auch auf einem 3G-Quick läuft und das auch besser läuft als auf einem 3G.
Ja, das sind so Sachen, die man sonst nicht hat, aber dass mir ein Feature, was das OS hat und mir bietet könnte, dass das nicht kommt, das finde ich einfach mal kacke. Vor allem dann zu diesen Bedingungen der Provider und nicht zu den Bedingungen von Apple. 20 Euro will die Telekom dafür haben?
Ich hab mit O2 telefoniert, die haben sich tatsächlich Mühe gegeben, mir zu helfen. Sie haben es nicht geschafft, sie haben mir per Mail ein Profile für 3.0 zugeschickt, was dann auch nicht signiert war. Wo ich dann im Wesentlichen sagen konnte, na guten Dank.
Bei O2 haben die ein Profile geschickt?
Die haben in O2 ein Profile zugeschickt. Was? Das hat ein bisschen Recherche gedauert.
War das signiert?
Nee, es war leider nicht signiert.
Geht ja auch nicht, Apple signiert die.
Naja, eben.
Also die haben sich die... Also klar, sonst hätte ich jetzt Tethering gehabt. Nee, nee, aber O2 würde mir helfen. Die probieren dafür zu sorgen, dass ich auf meinem iPhone Tethering nutzen kann, obwohl das offiziell nicht Supporten das Gerät. Und nicht mal die können's, bei Augenblick. Das ist echt bizarr. Ich hab, weil in Deutschland ein...
Verteilt die Telekom jetzt eigentlich schon dieses fein Profiles? Also ist man in der Lage, ein solches zu beziehen, um Tethering zu nutzen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Aber sie haben doch Preise announced.
Ja, aber das heißt doch nicht, dass das Produkt schon verfügbar ist.
Ach so, sie announced erstmal Preise und dann vergeht nochmal halb Jahr.
Man hat AT&T, MMS angekündigt. Und dass das mit den alten Verträgen plötzlich nicht mehr gehen soll, habt ihr auch mitbekommen, oder?
Ja, die sind ganz raus.
Die haben jetzt irgendwie neue Verträge, die Tethering dazubuchen können. Und die Verträge der ersten Generation, die eigentlich eine zweite SIM-Karte und Tethering und alles inklusive haben. Für euch gibt es keine Tethering, sondern es ist zu viel Arbeit.
Ja, das ist alles. Liebe Telekom, ihr seid echt so lame. Das ist wirklich das Schlimmste an euch, dass ihr so lame seid. Nicht, dass die anderen Telekom-Unternehmen nicht auch noch lame wären, aber obwohl man eigentlich wirklich auch noch überlegende Technologie hat. Telekom hat einfach mal alles. Die könnten alles so wunderbar zusammenpacken und ein gutes Paket draus machen. Und sie tun es einfach nicht. Ihr seid einfach lame. Und deswegen werde ich nicht Kunde bei euch. Das ist der Hauptgrund. Da ist es wirklich zum Heulen. Zum Heulen. Also das mit dem Tellering ist wirklich das erste, was mich echt nervt. Und das geht nicht. Ich hoffe, dass durch diese Liberalisierung, nämlich dass es jetzt quasi keine exklusiven Anbieter mehr gibt. Weil es gibt ja nur noch in Deutschland und in den USA, wenn ich das richtig sehe, oder? In jedem Land gibt es mehr als einen Anbieter.
UK auf jeden Fall. Ich kenne nicht alle Ländern, denen es...
Ich habe sie jetzt auch nicht einzeln abgehakt. Das waren Aussagen, die ich gelesen habe, denen bisher nicht ausreichend widersprochen wurde. Mir fällt aber jetzt so auch nichts ein. Aber in Hongkong ist es so, keiner weiß, was jetzt in China passiert. Da ist es ja jetzt, sieht es ja tatsächlich so aus, als ob sie da Crippled iPhones verkaufen würden. Das ist echt absurd.
In China? Da ist es ja nicht mehr erlaubt. Da dürfen Mobiltelefone keinen WLAN haben.
Na egal, die verkaufen ja in Hongkong da irgendwie schon seit Langem. Aber sie gehen halt nicht mit China Telekom zusammen, sondern mit diesen Unicom Leuten. Wie von mir, vor mehreren Ausgaben vorausgesagt. Und das ist alles ganz furchtbar und das stinkt. Naja, okay, gut. Ich denke das Thema iPhone und iPods haben wir damit auch ausführlich dargelegt oder haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen? Ah ja, hab ich schon auf iTunes 9 ausreichend rumgeschimpft, ich glaube nicht.
Ich finde ein iTunes 9 kleines Feature ganz toll. Und zwar... Achso, das hab ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt noch nicht gemacht. Und zwar, es gibt ja diese Möglichkeit, dass man sich oben die Interpreten einblenden lassen konnte in so einer vertikalen Liste und dann so... von dem ich das gerne genutzt habe. Also, dass man dieses zweigeteilte Fenster hatte, wo unten alle Songs aufgelistet waren und oben konnte man dann Interpretenalbum auswählen. Das hat aber immer sehr viel Platz weggenommen. Jetzt ist diese Liste einfach vertikal bei Bedarf. Diese Interpretenliste. Und dann so quasi wie im...
Wenn er sich das mal schick merken könnte, aber nee, muss man ja immer wieder ein- und ausschalten, weil das vergisst, wenn man es wieder nach oben bringt und so.
Wie er das nach oben bringt?
Man kann es ja auch wieder so machen, wie es vorher war. In B&U gibt es da so einen Punkt, aber der merkt sich das hier für Share-Dings nicht. So ein MTDA-PD-Server hat dann irgendwie...
Das war ich noch nicht überprüft.
Vergiss das immer.
Aber wenn du hier meinst, dass das eigentlich so langsam ist, was du aber dann meinst, sind Podcasts und Videos abspielen oder so ein Schnickschnack. Weil hier dieses Musik... Weil Musik sortieren und diese Tabelle, also deine Musik, das ist alles total flott geworden seit 8.0. Das Listen, Scrollen, Sortieren, Machen, Tun, das ist alles flutscht wie nix.
Also wie lange braucht es diese iPhone?
Bei 8.0 wurde es doch, haben sie auch schon gesagt, sie haben das da einmal beschleunigt.
Also ich muss natürlich jetzt mein frisch noch mal revitalisiertes OS jetzt noch mal neu testen und so. Aber es gibt einfach Dinge, die erst mit 9.0 ganz furchtbar broken waren und jetzt mit 9.0.1 so ein bisschen schneller sind. Aber dass dieses Programm performant ist, diese Behauptung kann nicht aufrechterhalten werden. Also iTunes ist einfach mal eine Schnecke und du kannst kein Video abspielen und gleichzeitig ein iPhone reinstecken und es läuft einfach mal flüssig weiter. Das geht einfach nicht. Sondern es ruckelt dann über einen Zeitraum von mindestens einer Minute, unregelmäßig immer wieder, bleibt es stehen, läuft weiter. Also die sind einfach in keinerlei Hinsicht auch nur im Ansatz da, wo sie eigentlich mit ihrem ganzen OS hinwollen, nämlich asynchrones Behavior und maximale Nutzung der Ressourcen. Ich verstehe auch nicht so richtig, warum es eigentlich alles so furchtbar lange dauert. Und meiner Meinung nach gibt es jetzt auch gar keinen Grund mehr, warum sie nicht iTunes in Coco neu programmieren. Nenn mir mal einen.
Das ist voll viel Arbeit.
Dass sie erst mal QuickTime fertig kriegen müssen.
Wahrscheinlich ist iTunes doch das größte Programm, das sie da haben.
Wieso müssen sie QuickTime fertig kriegen?
Da müssen sie erst mal neue Leute finden. Da muss man erst mal mit QuickTime nichts zu tun. Die haben doch iTunes. Ja, aber die Entwickler bei Apple werden gerade nicht lange Weile haben.
Ich meine, was machen denn? Ja, okay, gut. Sie haben zu wenig Leute am Team. Gut, ja, das machen wir.
Und dann müssen andere Leute noch das Tablet entwickeln und so.
Das hat ja damit nichts zu tun.
Eine Funktion, wie man Tessering auch in Zukunft abgeschaltet behält.
Da schauen sie in ihre Bildschirme. Und ich sitze hier leidend.
Nein, nein.
Das ist einfach langsam und scheiße.
Ja, iTunes ist scheiße.
Ich bin ja froh, dass sie zumindest mit dem Syncing so ein paar Fortschritte gemacht haben. Wo ich wirklich sagen muss, was besser geworden ist, ist zum Beispiel das Syncing von Fernsehsendungen. Ja, eines meiner Lieblingsfeatures. Das war vorher total broken, jetzt ist es irgendwie okay. Und jetzt siehst du auch schon vorher, was du synkst. Das ist wirklich ein riesen Vorteil. Trotz alledem.
Ich finde den iTunes-Storm unglaublich langsam. Also gerade wenn man das erste Mal draufklickt, bis er dann irgendwann mal da ist, da vergeht so viel Zeit.
Das ist echt sagenhaft. Was richtig broken ist bei iTunes 9, ist, warte mal, jetzt muss ich noch mal gucken, wo ich, ach nee, das scheinen sie auch gefixt zu haben. Okay, alles klar. Ich hatte mir bei 9 was notiert, was wohl jetzt nicht mehr gilt. Dann halt ich's mal. Oder?
Ach sag's, komm.
Na, ich bin ja jemand, der benutzt Scrollbars mit, wie heißt das schön? Scroll To Here.
Ach so, dass du an eine Stelle klickst.
Das ist meine erste Einstellung, die ich in einem neu installierten OS vornehme.
Also das, was der normale User mit einem Alt-Click in den Scrollbar erreichen würde.
Alt-Click, das geht?
Ja, seh ich auch gerade. Sogar bei iTunes.
Seit wann geht denn das?
Was du da machst, ist, dass du das Behavior einfach umdrehst.
Nee, ich dreh das nicht um, ich stell das so ein, wie es zu sein hat.
Ich stell das so ein, wie du das gerne hättest. Aber ich kann genau das Gleiche machen, nämlich halt einen Alt-Click an die Stelle mache.
Seit wann geht das denn?
Schon immer.
Hast du mir vor Jahren gezeigt und sogar glaube ich selber gesagt.
Ich? Nee.
Wer denn sonst? Ich wäre gar nicht auf die Wege gekommen.
Der Tim Prittler aus dem alternativen Universum.
Ich geh da hin, hier und normal klicke, geht da einen runter. Und wenn ich hier Alt festhalte, dann...
Okay, das ist bei mir auf jeden Fall die Folkbehaviour. Das haben sie bei iTunes 9 irgendwie vergeigt.
Da geht das nicht.
Nein, da war es halt anders. Das war wieder so ein Punkt, wo ich so auf dieses iTunes draufgeprallt bin. Und ich dachte so, oh weia, was habt ihr denn bitte für eine Code-Basis, wenn noch nicht mal Standard Scrollbar-Behaviour durchscheint. Das ist irgendwie das, was mich so macht.
Man kann auch immer merken, wenn die da am Scrollbar-Behaviour wieder mal rumgefuscht haben und nicht das Original Apple-Zeugs nehmen. Weil ich hab ja beide Scroll-Errors oben und unten. Da gibt es so einen Default in der Command-Land für.
Genau, der kann sich auch mit Secrets schön umsetzen.
Genau. Und in iTunes, da zickt der voll rum. Und komischerweise im Safari auch. Das heißt, die machen da ihr eigenes Scrolling-Zeugs.
Was heißt zickt rum?
Na, obwohl Safari geht jetzt gerade, aber meistens ist es so, dass wenn ich den oberen klicke, geht das Ding trotzdem nach unten. Und da muss ich ganz, ganz oben in die Ecke, damit er dann nach oben geht, fast schon außerhalb von dem eigentlichen Arrow-Bild. Können jetzt unsere Hörer nicht nachvollziehen, aber ja, habt ihr Pech gehabt.
Ich auch nicht so richtig. Nicht nur ihr könnt das nicht nachvollziehen.
In iTunes geht es auch gar nicht so richtig, weil der hat ja eigene Scrollbars.
Mir ist ja aufgefallen, wenn man sich Programme anguckt wie Tweety oder Twitterrific, die haben ja heutzutage gar keine Rollbalken mehr. Das ist ja alles so ein bisschen iPhone-Eska bei denen. Das ist mir schon aufgefallen.
Hier siehst du zum Beispiel iTunes, da hab ich nur noch zwei, wo war es unten, aber oben sind gar keine mehr, das heißt die Supporten, hast du jetzt irgendwie Echo reingemacht?
Ne, ich hab ein bisschen, Entschuldigung, ich hab den Gain ein bisschen aufgedreht, das ist wahrscheinlich zu viel Raum jetzt, ne?
Ja, warte für Raum gerade. Das wird zu viel Raum gegeben.
Das wird nie wieder vorkommen. Das wird nicht wieder vorkommen, Dennis.
Ja ne, aber iTunes, also iTunes müssen sie nicht nur neu machen, sondern die müssen das mal, also da muss man die Kartellbehörde her und muss man sagen, die müssen das ausblütten, das geht nicht. Da ist zu viel Zeug in einem Programm drin.
Das ist aber tatsächlich, da wird die Kartellbehörde dran müssen, oder? Das machen die von alleine, das ist so deren, das ist das iTunes-Betriebssystem, das wollen die glaube ich, das wollen die auf dem Mac haben, das wollen die auf dem Mac haben, das muss überall gleich aufsehen.
iPhone-Syncing-Musik organisieren und Syncing-Videos, du sollst sie mit im Store einkaufen, deine iPhone-Programme sollst du damit managen und dann auch noch, wo die erscheinen, auf dem iPhone, also das ist einfach too much.
Und an Kontakte synken und Kalender synken und alles.
Ja, dieses ganze iPhone-Gesynke, das muss da eindeutig mal raus.
Aber immerhin schaffen sie es noch, dass Palm nicht rein kann.
Ja, sie machen es ja auch, die Adressen können sie ja auch synken, aber sie holen ja vom Adressbuch, dann kann sie das mit der Musik auch so machen. Das ist in einem anderen Programm drin. Von mir aus können sie auch das iTunes verlassen. Und das Musik, also meine eigenen MP3s und Zeugs hier, MP4 ist irgendwie in ein anderes Tool schieben. Aber wollen sie natürlich, weil sie wollen ja, dass wenn ich klicke, dass ich dann auch ganz schnell beim Store bin. Aber eigentlich schreckt mich das mehr ab, als dass es mich unterstützt, schnell einzukaufen.
Die Blackberries haben ja jetzt einen Synkning-Tool, der auch die iTunes-Bibliothek übernehmen kann. Die machen ihr Synkning selber. Hattest du das?
Ich meine eigentlich, dass das iTunes dein Adressbuch synkt, ohne dass es deine Adressdaten selber verwaltet. Aber mit der Musik, da muss es unbedingt drin sein. Also es würde auch gehen. Oder mit den Fotos ja genau das gleiche. Die Fotos sind ja auch nicht in iTunes selbst. Sie sind ja in einem anderen Programm, aber das iTunes synkt halt auch Fotos. Und so könnte man die Musik eigentlich auch von iTunes mal theoretisch woanders hin auslagern. Was jetzt von den beiden Programmen iTunes heißt.
Dass man halt einfach eine Database hat. Ja, es ist alles durcheinander und es ist auch durcheinander, dass das irgendwie jetzt auch Filme beinhaltet, die dann in deinem Music-Ordner liegen und so. Das ist irgendwie auch alles total gar nicht.
Wobei haben sie das nicht mit iTunes 9 auch aufgeräumt?
Sie haben es aufgeräumt, aber nicht geändert. Also es liegt immer noch alles im iTunes Music Ordner. Und der ist anders.
Den hab ich mir noch nicht genauer an.
Ja, der hat jetzt mehr Ordner im Wesentlichen. Also du hast dann sozusagen für jedes Item auch immer noch einen Ordner, auch wenn es nur ein Item ist und so. Ich hab das umgestellt, das macht schon so ein bisschen Sinn, aber der große Wurf, finde ich, ist es nicht. Also es ist immer noch nicht so, wie du das eigentlich alles geordnet haben willst. Und was ich auch nicht verstehe, wo ich mir auch jedes Mal an den Kopf schlage, das ist, wenn du was löscht. Ja, das macht dann wirklich überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
Lösch mal was in iTunes.
Du weißt, was dann passiert? Nein. Du drückst Delete.
Dann kommt ein Mülleimer.
Nein.
Also Musik landet dann im Mülleimer.
Da kommt erstmal ein Are you sure? Gut, das kann man sich auch irgendwie wegklicken. Dann wird es removed und dann ist es nicht mehr in iTunes sichtbar. Dann kommt noch ein Dialog hoch.
Nein, da kommen nicht drei, zwei kommen da.
Und dann kommt der andere, der dich fragt, ob du die Datei trotzdem an dieser Stelle belassen möchtest oder tatsächlich löschen möchtest.
Stimmt, dann kann man sagen, auch in den Papierkorb bewegen.
Ja, was soll denn das? Also was heißt, wenn ich sie nicht löschen möchte, dann liegt die Datei in diesem Ordner rum, wo ich sie nie finde, weil sie mir iTunes nicht mehr anzeigt.
Nee, das ist dann total sinnvoll, wenn du die Musik nicht von deinem iTunes verwaltest.
Ja, wenn du die Musik verwaltest, dann kommt ja die Frage trotzdem.
Das heißt, er belässt eine Datei in einem von ihm verwalteten Ordner. Das heißt, er gibt sozusagen die Verwaltung einer Datei auf, obwohl er eigentlich alles dort drin verwalten will. Was bitte ist das? Und dann auch noch mit so kranken, modalen Dialogen. Ich kotze. Das ist das, wo dieses iTunes wirklich bekloppt ist. Weil ich meine, was kann denn das für einen Sinn haben? Es gibt Tools, die deinen iTunes-Ordner danach scannen, ob alle Dateien, die da rumliegen, auch in iTunes aufgeführt sind. Das hab ich irgendwann mal laufen lassen und bin komplett vom Stuhl gefallen. Wie viele Gigabyte an Daten auf einmal frei wurden von Sachen, die mir iTunes so nie gezeigt hat, die aber trotzdem in dem von ihm verwalteten Ordner rumliegen.
Ich finde das genau das genaue Gegenteil, fand ich immer total nervig. Ich hab jetzt erst relativ vor kurzer Zeit, bin ich umgestiegen auf dieses iTunes verwalten lassen und hatte vorher immer meine MP3s sonst wo und hab die nur in iTunes reingeschmissen. Dann hat man die gelöscht, dann hat man in iTunes so lustige, verwaiste Icons gehabt. Was besonders toll ist, wenn man...
Das ist auch geil, wenn du es andersrum machst.
Genau. Und da hab ich mich irgendwann aufgehört daran zu stören, an diesem merkwürdigen Fragezeichen. Und... Aber wenn man einen Apple TV synchronisiert, sagt jedes Mal, kommt jedes Mal eine Fehlermeldung. So, ah, das konnte ich nicht synchronisieren, weil das hab ich nicht gefunden. So, dann ist das... Dann hast du da diesen Dialog, das ist auch so ein richtig schöner Mac OS 9-Dialog, der viel zu klein ist, wo kaum der Name der Datei reinpasst. So eine Liste mit irgendwie den letzten sieben Dateien, die ich noch nicht synchronisieren konnte. Und dann kannst du anfangen, kannst suchen nach den Dateien, Copy and Paste gibt's selbstverständlich nicht, dass du einfach mal so den Namen des Songs, der jetzt fehlt, kopieren könntest, und dann kannst du ihn merken. Und es gibt auch nicht ne Funktion, die einfach mal alle Dateien aus deiner iTunes-Bibliothek rauslöscht, von denen er weiß, dass er sie nicht mehr findet.
Ja, das ist so krank.
Weg mit dem Scheiß.
Es ist so eine halbstarke Software, ja, die also rumprotzt, wie geil sie doch ist, aber irgendwie nicht den Arsch geputzt bekommt. Und irgendwie sein Zimmer nicht aufräumt. Und jetzt, ganz neu...
Tim wird alt, er fängt an, über halbstarke Software herzuziehen.
Ich werde alt?
Na ja, das ist so halbstark.
Wieso halbstark? Na halt einfach so angehbar Software. Die kommt irgendwie hierher mit dicken Muskelpaketen und so. Was weiß ich irgendwie, was es alles kann, aber ist einfach nicht in der Lage, sich den Mund abzuwischen. Homesharing, das nächste. Ja, was, ich meine, hallo, okay, gut, klar. Das mag jetzt für ein paar Leute eine Verbesserung sein, aber ich frage mich, für wen? Das ist geil für Leute, die fünf Computer haben.
Homesharing mit dem iPhone, das wär der Hammer.
Ja, aber bleiben wir nochmal bei diesem Homesharing. Was bitte soll das? Also wieso gibt es keine Lösung für Familien?
Ist das nicht die Lösung für Familien?
Nein.
Wieso nicht?
Weil du einen Account verwenden musst. Jeder Computer, der mit demselben...
Du hast zwei Accounts in deiner Familie?
Aber man kann doch...
Natürlich. In jeder Familie hat jeder seinen eigenen Account. Ich bitte dich.
Aber man kann sich doch mit einem Account bei mehreren Rechner... Also du kannst doch auch an einem Rechner zwei Accounts erlaubt haben.
Wie?
Also du kannst doch, wenn du Musik von dem einen heißt, kannst du doch die Musik von dem einen abspielen und dann, also zum Beispiel dein Home-Account und wenn jetzt dein Sohn mal seine Musik an deinem MacBook abspielen will, dann könntest du den immer noch autorisieren. Und das wirkt sich nicht auch auf Home-Sharing aus?
Ich kann den nicht so ganz folgen.
Man kann noch mehr als einen Rechner... Man kann noch mehr als einen Rechner...
Einen Rechner.
Einen User gleichzeitig autorisieren und einen iTunes, oder? Oder fliegt dann der andere automatisch raus?
Wie denn?
Ich glaube, in dem Moment, in dem man auf eine MP3, also auf ein geschütztes M4A von irgendjemanden klickt. Auf eine M4P-Datei.
Man kann mehrere Accounts...
Also ich möchte mich jetzt nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster legen.
Ja, aber was heißt denn, dass ich dann auf meinem Rechner, dass dann sozusagen sich jemand dann hier auch noch mal... Ich verstehe es nicht. Was sagt denn der Chat?
Der Chat zeigt, dass also Homesharing, dass es da nicht so... Also es geht wohl, aber hat einfach keinen...
Was geht? Die Frage ist doch, was will man? Du willst doch, wenn du eine Wohnung hast, wo mehrere Leute wohnen. Was willst du da? Da willst du ein Archiv, was du überall abspielen kannst.
Ja geil, und das will ich in der Firma auch.
Wenn ich was kaufe, soll das meiner ganzen Familie automatisch zur Verfügung stehen. Das willst du irgendwie zentral haben.
Zentral will ich es nicht haben.
Na aber wie denn sonst? Sonst muss ja jeder sein Rechner aufgeklappt haben.
Wo ist es denn zentral?
Das geht ja auch schon nicht.
Das wäre das.
Dann geht einer aus dem Haus, nimmt sein Rechner mit, hat seine Musik nicht.
Das wäre mein Wunsch, dass man auf die Time-Capsule seine Musik raufschmeißt und dass die irgendwie da ist. Das wär's. Groß genug ist der Scheiß dazwischen.
Genau, da ist Platz irgendwie. Du machst deine Back-up-Stars.
Und vor allem, dass ich sagen kann, spiel mal die Musik und ich klappe meinen Rechner zu und der spielt für mich meine Musik weiter. Zum Beispiel gleich noch vom iPhone ferngestellt, weil dann geht der Spaß erstmal richtig los.
Auf deine Airpodexpress, die du bei mir genannt hast.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, okay, okay. Er kann's. Ja, was denn?
Aber ich meine, das hätte zum Beispiel, sobald ich meine Wohnung verlasse, könnte ich dann keine Musik mehr hören, wenn die nur zentral auf dem Time-Sharing liegt.
Was? Nein.
Du kannst ja zusätzlich auf deinen Rechner packen, wenn du willst, aber...
Er sinnt das einfach da weg. Der macht doch eh einen Backup und überträgt die ganzen Daten. Die liegen doch da sowieso rum.
Ach so, das?
Zum Beispiel. Es liegt doch da alles rum.
Es liegt doch da alles rum.
Es ist doch da. Es ist doch nicht so, dass es nicht da wäre. Es ist da. Es wird bloß nicht benutzt. Okay, ich sehe ja ein, ein Backup ist das eine. So, ein Medienarchiv ist das andere. Aber mein Gott, da zieht man sich halt einfach eine neue Unterhose an und setzt sich an den Tisch und programmiert den Kack. Das kann doch nicht so schwierig sein. Das wollen alle haben. Stattdessen dieses komische, beschnittene, bekloppte hin und her von ja, nein, aber hier vielleicht und wenn du das aufklappst, dann könnte ich das vielleicht sehen und und so. Das versteht auch keiner. Also noch nicht mal ich peil, was sie überhaupt wollen. Es ist alles nur irgendwie DRM und du darfst nicht und du darfst nicht und du darfst nicht. Und das ist irgendwie das Schlimme in dieser ganzen Denke. Und das steckt da auch immer noch voll drin. Und obwohl sie uns DRM-freie Musik organisiert haben, die Jungs, ja, ist es beileibe nicht so, dass sie bei Video da einen komplett anderen Kurs fahren würden.
Jaja, und bei Apps.
Es ist so, dass sie da einen komplett anderen Kurs fahren.
Ich würde gerne mit meinem iPhone auch die Musik von meinem Rechner hören können, ohne dass ich sie erst runterladen muss. Sondern dass mein Rechner meine Musik auf meinem iPhone streamt. Damit ich abends in dem Bett liegen kann und meine ganze Musik mir anhören kann.
Dazu hab ich noch was.
Aber das kannst du nicht mehr zu erstreamen oder sowas. Wie heißt das mit dieser Airfoil-Erweiterung quasi?
Nee, hab ich schon mal probiert, das ging nicht.
Das ging nicht?
Was funktioniert nicht?
Dass die Musik, die hier ist, dass ich die mir hier anhören kann, ohne dass ich sie so runterladen muss, sondern Streaming ist so live-mäßig.
Dass du dein iPhone nur als Lautsprecher verwendest? Ja, Airfoil.
Aber nicht nur als Lautsprecher, ich will auch dann hier auf dem iPhone aussuchen können, was ich höre.
Achso, dass du sozusagen wie mit iTunes von einem Rechner aus einfach, ja, ja. Das geht nicht, du kannst nur Fernbedienung.
Das vermisse ich auch exakt nie.
Weil das Tool ist ja alles schon da, dieses Apple Remote. Und eigentlich fehlt jetzt nur noch der Play-Button. Dann sollen sie es herholen und abspielen. Das wäre total geil. Weil da würde ich eigentlich fast gar keine Musik mehr drauf machen. Also ein bisschen, was ich unterwegs hören will, aber für zu Hause.
Ja, aber das halte ich ehrlich gesagt auch für einen relativ exotischen Wunsch. Zu Hause liegen, seine Musik nicht auf dem iPhone haben wollen, Rechner läuft, aber nicht über Lautsprecher hören wollen, sondern über Kopfhörer aus irgendwelchen...
Mein Rechner bleibt in meinem Zuhausebüro stehen, an meinem Schreibtisch. Ich gehe ins Bett irgendwie, will noch ein bisschen Musik hören, vom Einschlafen, weiß aber noch nicht genau was. Und das weiß ich erst, wenn ich im Bett liege, weil im Bett weiß ich ja, wie ich einschlafen will. Und dann würde ich mich zu meinem Rechner connecten, würde so durchscrollen und so.
Kauft ihr eine AirPod Express, schließt sie an die Anlage, die im Schlafzimmer steht, und fertig. Na über die Apple Remote. Genauso wie du das machen willst.
Du kriegst das auf den Kopfhörer.
Dann hörst du es eben laut.
Du kannst auch den Kopfhörer in die AirPod Express stecken, das stimmt eigentlich. Das kostet 81 Euro, toll. Aber ist das irgendwie okay, der Programmierer ist wahrscheinlich...
Ja, dann sitzt du aber nicht da, sondern woanders. Das Schöne am iPhone ist, du hast es halt immer da, wo du bist. Da sitzt du auf der Bank, in der Küche. Dann ist halt das KV.
Es ist ja nicht so, als ob man aufs iPhone keine Musik draus spielt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon bemerkt habt, man kann auf dieses iPhone auch Musik draus spielen.
Aber man kann es echt draus spielen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Musik ich zu Hause hab.
Man kann streamen, sie haben ganz toll Streaming jetzt eingebaut. Nur ihr scheiß iTunes kann da nicht draus spielen. Ich meine, warum?
Ja, Streaming wäre...
Ich sag dir mal, wie man es machen kann. Hier, ITV, diese Software, das Fernsehen, die haben jetzt ein neues Update. Also ich sag gleich, es läuft noch nicht richtig. Das ist irgendwie alles noch buggy, aber es ist im Prinzip schon mal alles angelegt und ich schätze mal, mit dem übernächsten Update müssen sie es auf die Reihe kriegen. Also du kannst ja, das ist ja dieses Tool, was so Fernsehen macht. Und die haben jetzt einen iTunes-HTTP-Video-Streaming-Client mit eingebaut. Das heißt, du kannst mit der ITV-App vom iPhone direkt auf deine Applikation drauf connecten. Und das auch übers Internet, nicht nur im Heimladen.
Achso, Homeshare und mit zwei Accounts klappt wohl laut Chat.
Ja, das wurde da geschrieben, aber mir ist nicht so ganz klar, wie das dann gedacht ist. Das heißt, alle teilen sich mit allen Accounts alles?
Würde in jeder Firma, jeder mit jedem voll und so weiter.
Okay, das können wir gleich mal ausrubben. Ich erkläre das mal kurz mit dem ITV zu Ende. So, und dann kannst du hier irgendwie dir Fernsehen auf dem iPhone angucken. Live, gestreamt, von deinem Mac.
Endlich, da wartet man seit 20 Jahren drauf.
Fernsehen, dass es das nochmal erleben darf.
Ja, das ist ein Problem. Das ist halt nur Fernsehen. Das ist aber rein technologisch, weil die ist ganz interessant.
Guck mal, ich kann Fernsehen auf dem... Oh Gott, das ist langweilig.
Da kommt noch was anderes. Was der nächste große Bringer ist, ist halt, das nächste ist halt nicht, dass die Leute ein Baby-Phone mit sich rumschleppen, sondern ein Baby-TV, wo sie gleich gucken können, was irgendwie gerade Baby so macht. Ehrvoll.
Vollüberwachung der Kinder. Jawoll, mit sich gleich dran gewöhnen.
Aber das ist tatsächlich... Baby-Phone ist auch schon überwacht. Das Baby-Phone ist echt eine gute Idee. Das machen wir nochmal.
Das ist mit allen anderen Sachen genauso. Vorm Überwachung. Du bist nicht zu Hause, willst mal gucken, was da los ist.
Nee, aber Baby-Phone finde ich eine spannende Anwendung. Home-Überwachung? Na ja, dann musst du halt immer...
Baby-Überwachung, Home-Überwachung, das ist alles Überwachung.
Normale Menschen machen ihren Rechner aus, wenn sie weggehen. Das heißt, sie haben... Ah, ist echt?
Quatsch.
Jaja, ich bin auch einer von denen.
Und jetzt sag nicht, du machst sogar noch Shutdown.
Nee, ich klappe den zu. Und meistens nehme ich ja sogar mit, insofern muss ich den zu klappen, bleibt mir eh nichts anderes übrig. Aber wer schon einmal das entwürdigende Gefühl gesehen hat, zwei Elternpärchen, die jeweils mit ihrem Babyphone vor demselben Italiener sitzen, weil das das Einzige ist, was der einzige Italiener in ihrer Reichweite ist, und auch das einzige Pärchen, was mit ihnen freiwillig weggeht, weil die halt auch im Nachbarhaus wohnen und auch per Babyphone erreichbar sein wollen, denen sieht man an, dass sie über eine iPhone-App, mit der man das Baby hören kann, total dufteglücklich werden.
Naja, aber sie können ja trotzdem nicht so weit weg von zu Hause, weil im Notfall müssen sie auch schnell zu Hause sein.
Ja, aber außer funkreich weiter, das sind doch irgendwie 50 Meter oder sowas. Da kannst du schon mal einkaufen gehen oder so.
Du hast übrigens eine Message in deinem Work, du solltest ja mal antworten. Eine private Message.
Ja, ich nehme meinen Rechner nun mal nicht aufgeklappt mit.
Ah, da schicken wir noch eine Mail hin. War das eine Antwort?
Ich hab den hier am Adium.
So, so, während der Sendung.
Natürlich.
Keine Privatschats während der Aufnahmen.
Uralte Connections.
Private Internetnutzung während der Aufnahme ist verboten.
Ja, wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob wir noch so Themen haben?
Es geht noch schlimmer, jetzt kriege ich sogar schon Waves während der Sendung. Wo die Datenwellen an den Strand trecken. Da ist das noch erlebender. Wollen wir noch über Google Wave reden? Wollen wir jetzt über Google Wave reden? Aber wo waren wir denn gerade? Wir waren bei iPhone, wir waren bei ITV.
Eigentlich waren wir bei den iPods.
Wenn wir noch bei iPhone sind, und wir haben es ja vorhin auch schon angedeutet, vielleicht nehmen wir mal was Aktuelles, weil das finde ich sehr interessant. Habt ihr dieses Announcement von Adobe mitbekommen?
Wie mit dem arm optimierten Flash?
Also es gab zwei Announcements. Das erste Announcement ist, Version 10.1 wird endlich funktionieren.
Auf Mobile Devices meinst du?
Ja genau.
Und davon gibt es eine Beta. Und dann noch zusätzlich aber, dass man normale Programme irgendwie in Flash coden kann, da dann so einen Konverter gibt, der dann ein richtiges App draus macht, was man dann sogar in den App Store stellen kann. Und da gibt es wohl sogar auch schon drei, die im Store drin sind. Hab jetzt aber vergessen welche.
Ich auch. Das sind gar nicht so wenige, die schon drin sind. Irgendwie so ein, ich glaube so ein South Park Character Creator und irgendwie sowas.
Aber irgendwie fühlt sich das so an wie so die Real Basic Programme früher auf dem OS X. Könnt ihr euch noch erinnern? Real Basic Programme waren immer scheiße und ich glaube da kommt auch sowas bei raus.
Ja, weil ich sag, habt ihr geschneit, was für eine Technologie zum Ansatz kommt? Ja, LLVM, genau.
Weil Adobe da nämlich auch ganz dicke mit drin hängt.
So sieht's aus, die fanden das nicht schon immer ganz toll. Und die waren da schon seit längerer Zeit dabei, Flash Runtime, LLVM da irgendwie rum zu experimentieren. Und jetzt wissen wir auch, was sie gemacht haben. Das heißt, sie haben jetzt ein Frontend für LLVM geschrieben, wo sie quasi ihren Flash-Kram und auch ihr ganzes Action-Script in LLVM-Bytecode übersetzt.
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Doch.
Wieso? Weil das interpretiert werden muss.
Nein, nein.
Klar.
Nein.
Das machen sie auch alle. Es gibt ja mittlerweile einen C64-Eben.
Das weiß ich aber eigentlich.
Nein, wird nicht.
Aber monobasic.
Stimmt nicht. LLVM ist der Compiler-Bytecode. Das ist der Zwischen des Pseudocodes des Compilers. Und der wird dann in Arm-Code übersetzt.
Auf dem iPhone oder vorher?
Beim Compilen.
Ach so.
Das heißt, man kann Flash-native Programme entwickeln. Das ist der totale Hammer eigentlich.
Wobei ich mich gerade, wo ich gerade drüber nachdenke, kommt so eine kleine Zäsur, weil sie sagen ja, dass es nur auf dem iPhone läuft, aber nicht im Simulator, weil sie nur Arm unterstützen würden. Das heißt, sie machen die Compilation sozusagen auch komplett. Sie greifen nicht in Xcode ein, sondern sie haben sozusagen die vollständige Compilation und unterstützen nur als Backend. Was mich ein bisschen wundert, weil wenn sie über LLVM gehen, müssten sie an der Stelle genau davon entkoppelt sein. Also LLVM ist ja drei Schichten. Du hast ein Frontend, wo ein Compiler irgendetwas in LLVM Bytecode übersetzt. Nicht zu verwechseln mit Java Bytecode. Das ist eine ähnliche Idee. Du hast eine Virtual Machine. Diese Virtual Machine ist aber nicht dazu da, um dann ausgeführt zu werden.
Sondern um nur weiter übersetzt zu werden.
Genau. Aber auch um Runtime-Optimierung und so weiter zu ermöglichen. Da hab ich mal einen CRI-Droier gemacht. Wie auch immer. Dann halt von dem zweiten Level auf den dritten. Da kommen dann die Optimizations rein. Und am dritten Level erzeugst du den eigentlichen Code. Das ist der Weg, den Adobe jetzt geht, um Flash als Ossering-Tool zu verwenden. Der Vergleich mit Real Basic ist so schlecht eigentlich nicht. Wobei ich glaube, dass die beim Real Basic aber schon im Prinzip das ganze API zugänglich gemacht haben. Das heißt, du hast schon einen Carbon-API gehabt.
Ja, du konntest da richtig viel entwickeln. Also naja. Sie haben es immer noch.
Das war doch immer so ein bisschen Real Basic-mäßig. Deswegen hat es so gestunken.
Das war aber besser als viele andere Ansätze, die ich gesehen habe.
Real Basic war nicht so schlecht. Ich glaube, das Hauptproblem bei Real Basic war, man konnte gute Programme drin schreiben, man konnte aber natürlich auch totale Scheiße drin machen.
Das geht ja mit allen Sprachen.
Ja, aber gerade weil Anfänger sich darauf gestürzt haben, die noch nie vorher eine App designt haben.
Klar, da steht ja Basic dran.
Genau, und das war auch schön. Also es hat echt Spaß gemacht. Ich hab damit ein bisschen gearbeitet. Es hat echt Laune gemacht. Man konnte schön einfach, war objektorientiert und alles.
Und bei Real Basic wollen wir jetzt nicht reden.
Nee, aber auf jeden Fall konnte es, es war schon verdammt nah dran. Es war nicht 100% die echte Apple API, aber schon verdammt gut.
Wie auch immer, da schien das Betriebssystem noch durch. Also das Real Basic hat ja schon versucht, eine Alternative zu sein. Flash in dem Sinne ignoriert das iPhone OS komplett. Du hast keine User Interface-Controls. Was wahrscheinlich auch so schnell nicht kommen wird, weil da hat Flash sozusagen intern gar nichts da. Doch. Das ist also eigentlich nur für Games.
Nee, nee, das würde ich jetzt nicht zwangsläufig so sagen. Ich hab mich nicht mit beschäftigt. Aber es gibt schon seit einiger Zeit bei Flash auch so bietet Adobe direkt so Controls mit. Die sehen dann immer Flashy aus. Also die sehen nicht aus wie native Bedienelemente. Aber es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn Adobe die einfach auswechseln könnte dann auf ein iPhone und sagen, okay, da wo jetzt hier so eine Flash-Kombo-Box war, da machen wir jetzt mal das entsprechende iPhone-Pang-Dar.
Ja, aber warum solltest du ein Flash nehmen? Ich denke, Flash wird...
Weil viele Leute Flash können, Menschenskinder.
Ja, aber was machen die Leute damit? Damit machen sie irgendwie bunten Multimedia-Klimbim und Spiele. Und dafür ist es gedacht, die haben sowieso vom Start weg ihr eigenes User-Interface und da ist überhaupt nichts iPhone-y. Das heißt, für General-Purpose-Applikationen taucht das Flash gar nicht.
Für Dobies ist es deswegen toll, weil die das natürlich dann nicht nur fürs iPhone machen, sondern die übersetzen auch gleich für Android und für jeden anderen Scheiß, der da so kommen mag. Genau.
Naja, sie versuchen da ein bisschen ihren Arsch zu retten.
Dafür, dass Apple sie niemals so reinlassen wird, finde ich das einen echt okayen Ansatz.
Weil sie wenigstens mal über Technology versuchen und nicht über irgendeinen anderen Scheiß.
Aber man darf halt nicht übersehen, das bedeutet nicht, dass damit Flash-SWF-Dateien in irgendeiner Form auf dem iPhone ausgeführt werden können. Das geht nicht und das wird auch nicht gehen und das wird auch Apple weiterhin verhindern.
Ziemlich sicher.
Ja, fand ich aber auf jeden Fall interessant, wie LLVM jetzt auch, naja, also das wird jetzt mittlerweile so richtig heißer Scheiß. Das haben wir ja letztes Mal im Prinzip auch schon festgestellt. Noleo und den ganzen Optimierungen.
Ich kann noch mal dazu ganz kurz was sagen, dann hab ich es hinter mir. Die Freebies, die Jungs sind ja LLVM auch ganz geil und sind da gerade dabei. Es gibt wohl schon einen laufenden Kernel, der mit LLVM und C lang compiled wurde und ich hab mal gefragt, wie viel schnell es ist, konnte er nicht so richtig sagen, aber er hat einen anderen Test gemacht, er hat irgendwie OpenSSL oder ein Kryptozeugs damit kompiliert und da Laufzeit-Tests gemacht und das LLVM C lang Zeugs war ca. knappe 10% schneller. Also nur durch Neuübersetzen ohne irgendwelche anderen Optimierungen.
Und die Compilation dürfte wahrscheinlich auch um Faktor 10 schneller gewesen sein.
Nee, man sagt so 2-3.
2-3?
Was ja schon ordentlich ist.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Das wird alles schicken.
Mein Reset-Generator an LLVM wird einfach noch richtig viel Wind machen. So. Ich hab hier ein bisschen zu viele Daten auf meinem Computer. Tja, du hast vorhin gesagt, iTunes funktioniert nicht mehr mit Palm. Du weißt, dass das...
Jetzt geht's gerade wieder.
Bei dem letzten Update geht's gerade wieder.
Aber haben sie nicht kurz vorher alle gesagt, wir geben's auf und dann später kam, jetzt geht's wieder? Was war denn das für ein Ding?
Nee, sie haben nicht gesagt, wir geben's auf. Es kam eine neue Version von Palm OS heraus und das konnte es dann nicht. Dann haben sie gesagt, sie werden's wohl aufgeben. Und kurze Zeit später haben sie es doch wieder gemacht.
Ja, brauchst du die jetzt sofort? Ach so, dann nimm einfach meine.
Verstehe.
Andere hab ich nicht.
Wollen wir über Valve ein bisschen reden?
Lass uns über Valve reden.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Aber wir werden dann wieder zu iPhone und so weiter und Smartphone kommen. Wir müssen noch Nokia bashen.
Oh, dann krieg ich dann bitte auch noch Microsoft. Bitte auch noch Microsoft, bitte auch noch Microsoft.
Aber Nokia, da hatten wir doch letztes Mal schon, dass die jetzt das machen, was du schon letztes Mal gesagt hast, nämlich dass die...
Ja, letztes Mal hatten wir das glaube ich noch nicht, das kam kurz danach. Ja, dass sie jetzt QT machen.
Das hatten wir doch beim letzten Mal erwähnt.
Ich erwähne das schon seit mehreren Monaten, dass das meine Erwartung ist. Jetzt haben sie das angekündigt. Ich war ja noch einen Moment etwas verwundert, weil sie ja jetzt dieses Maemo gepusht haben. So, also sie sagen jetzt tatsächlich, dass Maemo eigentlich ihre Zukunftsplattform ist. Moment, womit sie meiner ursprünglichen Aussage, dass sie auf Linux gehen, quasi gefolgt sind. Ich war bloß überrascht, dass es halt dieses Maemo...
Ich glaube, es heißt Memo, oder? Ich sag Memo.
Ich finde Maemo irgendwie schöner. Wie auch immer Memo.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie es ausgesprochen wird, aber...
Maemo. La la la, Maemo ist GTK.
Ja, genau.
Maemo ist übrigens auch mal so im Clubumfeld entwickelt worden.
Ach so, ja, das ist GTK. Das sieht man auf sehr, sehr vielen Programmen an, dass die einfach nur...
Genau, das sieht man ihnen irgendwie an und so. Und das ist halt hier irgendwie... Die Gimper waren da mal sozusagen mal Geburtshelfer bei dem ganzen Kram, als man noch nicht wusste, was das irgendwie alles mal ergeben sollte. Wie auch immer. Mich verwundert jetzt, dass sie sozusagen ein System, dessen ganzen GUI-Genese GTK basiert ist, dass sie da jetzt QT als ihr Development verkünden. Ich meine, ich habe damit gerechnet, dass sie auf QT setzen, weil auf was bitte sonst? Trotzdem starten sie quasi jetzt mit einem OS, was eigentlich durch GTK geprägt ist. Also wo sie keine, zumindest soweit ich informiert bin, vielleicht ist da unter der Haube schon irgendwas passiert, was ich jetzt übersehen habe. Ich will da jetzt gar nicht so den, ich weiß, alles Anspruch haben, aber es war halt einfach GTK und GTK und QT sind einfach mal zwei verschiedene Sachen. Die haben einfach vollkommen verschiedene Ansätze. Und ja, ich hab einfach nach wie vor mal eine Zweifel, dass sie damit, dass sie rechtzeitig kommen. Also wenn sie das irgendwie vor drei Jahren gebracht hätten oder vor vier Jahren, dann hätten sie da irgendwie echt noch Welle machen können. Aber sie sind so weit davon entfernt. Und hast du diese Demos gesehen, wo sie dieses Mal Emo gezeigt haben? Da musst du dir echt nur mal angucken, wie sie da so scrollen und wie mit dem zweiten und mit dem dritten versuchen, dass es ruckelt und alles und so.
Ja, nee, hab ich noch nicht gesehen. Also ich hab ja mal bei Nokia in die Mail geschickt, ob sie uns nicht mal ein Testgerät von diesem N900 schicken können. Ich hab nicht mal eine Antwort auf die Mail gekriegt. Bestimmt haben die gedacht, ah, diese bösen Podcaster, mit denen wollen wir nichts zu tun haben. Die meckern bestimmt nur wieder.
Das stimmt.
Aber es gibt ja noch was anderes zu meckern. Habt ihr die Reviews von Windows Mobile 6.5 gelesen?
Ich hab so nebenbei gesehen, dass davon keiner so richtig Kenntnis genommen hat.
So richtig Kenntnis genommen hat?
Nee, die haben es schlimmer.
Die haben gesagt, es ist scheiße.
Also ich hab ja so ein paar Überschriften aufgeschrieben. Gizmodo meinte, there's no excuse for this. Mobile Crunch meinte, it still sucks. Das war die Überschrift. Ein Teil aus dem Artikel war wie.hate.sis.keyboard. Das scheint wirklich ein totales Drama zu sein.
Und ohne Stift geht immer noch nix.
Sie haben im Vergleich zu 6.1, kommen wir zu den positiven Teilen, der Browser ist wohl deutlich besser geworden. Der ist jetzt ungefähr auf Internet Explorer 7 Niveau.
Ich hab irgendwo gelesen, wo jemand meinte, das einzige, wofür man den Browser verwenden möchte, ist nicht ein altes.
Schöner runterzulauen. Aber da der Telefonhersteller ja will, dass du sein Telefon magst, wird er wahrscheinlich von vornherein anderen Browsern mitinstallieren.
Ich habe gehört, dass Microsoft Deutschland mittlerweile aufgehört hat, ihren Mitarbeitern zu verbieten, iPhones zu betreiben.
Weil die Kündigungsrate zu hoch war?
Weil sie wohl eingesehen haben, dass sie gegen die Wand laufen und dass die Leute dann irgendwann einfach nicht mehr produktiv sind.
Ja, aber entschuldigt mal bitte, erlaubt euren Leuten das bessere Gerät, damit sie wenigstens was abgucken können. Ich meine, nicht mal das kriegt ihr auf die Reihe. So eine Buchung kennen die nicht. Was ich darüber gelesen habe, ist, es gibt da dieses Startmenü, das haben sie ja komplett überarbeitet. Das ist ja jetzt so eine dreispaltige Liste, wo dann so die Icons alle so nebeneinander sind. Und damit das nicht aussieht wie bei der Konkurrenz mit den Äpfelchen, ist die mittlere Spalte so ein bisschen nach unten gesetzt. Diese Icons kann man umsortieren, ihr glaubt nicht wie. Es gibt genau eine Möglichkeit, einen Befehl, um die Icons umzusortieren und der heißt Move this Icon to top. Es gibt keinen Up, es gibt keinen Down, es gibt keinen...
Ist das nicht feige, über Microsoft zu reden?
Feige? Wieso feige?
Na ja, du schlägst irgendwie auf Leute ein, die auf Boden liegen und bluten.
Ja komm, jetzt mit diesem HTC Touch, äh Quatsch HTC Touch, mit diesem, wie heißt der? Mit diesem Zune HD, da haben ja alle gesagt, für Microsoft verhältnissen gar nicht so schlecht.
Gib doch jetzt mal hier die restlichen Daten.
Lass es doch, du kennst doch meine Adresse, man. Du fährst ja alle zwei Wochen hier.
Ja, aber deswegen weiß ich doch die Postleitzahlen nicht.
Okay, damit du wieder mitmachst. Führen sie aus. Führen sie beim Thema.
Aber 65 ist doch eh nur ein kurzer Vorreiter, dass demnächst die 7 kommt, oder?
Bestimmt. Das machen die übermorgen.
Ja, Ende 2010 oder so.
Vielleicht sind wir schon am Abschluss. Nokia hat doch jetzt gesagt, sie machen jetzt ihr neues Zeug da.
Nokia hat doch eh noch nie Windows Mobile gemacht.
Nokia macht kein Windows Mobile.
Die haben doch so unglaublich große Kunden wie Sony Ericsson?
Nein. Microsoft hat eigentlich nur noch einen einzigen Kunden.
Nach wie vor HTC.
Und der geht zunehmend auch auf andere Sachen.
Auf Android, um es jetzt mal ganz genau zu sagen.
So sieht es aus. Also, wie gesagt, wir brauchen glaube ich über Microsoft im Mobile-Markt, brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr reden. Also die sind jetzt weg. Die sind einfach nicht mehr da.
Selbst Steve Baume hat gesagt, dass...
Aber die neuen Phones sollen jetzt Windows Phones heißen. Hat sich das Marketing eingelassen.
Ja, das ist dann auch der Sargnagel, damit die Leute wissen, wovon sie wegrennen müssen.
Das werden die noch umdrehen, damit das schlechte Image von Windows Phones Windows nicht auf Windows abfärbt.
Die werden sich auch die Sieben bei ihrem Mobile-Phone wahrscheinlich dann auch nochmal schenken und das irgendwie dann wiederum irgendwie anders nennen.
XP.
Weil es dann zu dem Zeitpunkt mit Windows Sieben schon wieder vollkommen verbrannt ist. Aber Bauma gibt es ja eh nicht mehr lange, hast du gesagt, ne?
Ich hab das nicht gesagt, das sagt The Next Web. Also die haben mal so lustige Sachen gemacht. Was ist eigentlich, was ist mit Steve Bauma? Wie lange wird der es noch machen? Und die sagen nicht mehr allzu lange.
Wer ist denn The Next Web?
Irgend so eine lustige kleine Webseite, die ich mal lese und die haben sich ein bisschen aus dem Fenster gelehnt.
Sind die irgendwie kompetent? Ich kenne die nicht, deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob die irgendwas können.
Die sind so, ich sag mal, das ist ein bisschen so eine Web 2.0-Block aus europäischer Sicht. Also es ist nicht so Tech-Crunch-mäßig so mega veramerikanisiert, sondern die sehen das auch immer noch ein bisschen aus der europäischen Sicht. Und darum ist es ganz spannend. Das sind aber einfach ganz okaye Argumente, die die einfach mal zu liefern haben. Zum einen wird er im Januar seit exakt 10 Jahren CEO sein. Und das ist natürlich immer ein guter Moment, um zu sagen, ich mach das jetzt seit 10 Jahren. Lassen wir es mal lieber.
Oder dass es einfach selber geht.
Warum nicht? Bevor er bevor er bevor er. Also was ist ein schöner?
Ich denke, der stirbt im Herzinfarkt. Da warte ich sowieso schon seit langem drauf.
Der ist schon im Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Aber eigentlich bei jeder großen Firma schmeißen ihre Chefs immer gleich raus, wenn irgendwas nicht so richtig läuft.
Warum eigentlich da nicht?
Bei Microsoft. Weil es bei Microsoft ja eigentlich läuft.
Also deren Aktienkurs hat sich...
Ein Business-mäßig machen die einfach immer noch Asche.
Der Aktienkurs hat sich mal eben mehr als halbiert in den zehn Jahren. Ja gut, aber...
Also entscheidend ist irgendwie...
Der Aktienkurs hat sich halbiert? Nach diesem Crash aber jetzt vor kurzem.
Ne, ne. Guck mal hier, das ist so die Kurve. Also der hat es 2001 mal schön nachgelassen, klar. Und dann hat er sich auf niedrigen Niveau eingependelt, bei ungefähr 30 Dollar.
So kann man das nicht sehen. Das erste war die erste Dotcom-Blase, da sind sie alle abgestürzt. Das müsste man irgendwie rausrechnen. Und das ist die zweite Dotcom-Blase, da sind sie nochmal abgestürzt. So gesehen sind die relativ stabil.
Na guck mal, seitdem sind sie wieder gestiegen.
Microsoft...
Microsoft verdient immer noch mehr Geld als andere. Jemals haben auch nur Zahlen aneinander schreiben können, jedes Quartal.
Aber so viel ist auch nicht mehr, ne?
Es wird weniger und... Oder sagen wir mal zumindest...
Die haben jetzt nur noch doppelt so großen Gewinn wie Apple, aber brauchen dafür den dreivierfachen Umsatz.
Also im Vergleich zu Apple, also der Abstand zwischen Apple und Microsoft ist kleiner geworden. Andererseits ist es so oder so schwierig, die beiden Unternehmen zu vergleichen, da sie halt unterschiedlich...
So Apple mit Birnen vergleichen.
Apple mit Birnen, ja. Sie machen halt andere Sachen. Also erstens hat Microsoft eine ganze Menge Geschäftsfelder, die Apple nicht hat und auch ihr Ansatz im Markt ist halt ein anderer. Aber gut, das wissen wir ja alle. Ich finde das auch nicht so wichtig. Ich glaube da bei meiner Kernaussage, die Relevanz von Microsoft sinkt. Während wir in den 90er Jahren ein von allem übertünchtes Computingwesen hatten, wo es einfach ohne Microsoft kein einziger Standard mehr durchzusetzen war, ist es mittlerweile andersrum. Mittlerweile kann Microsoft keinen einzigen Standard mehr durchsetzen. Also ich kann mich schon gar nicht mehr erinnern, weil sie das letzte Mal irgendwas durchgesetzt haben. Das ist jetzt schon wirklich lange, lange her.
Also auch da war die Aussage in diesem Artikel.
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Standard setzen.
Ja, nichts hat geklappt irgendwie. Was sie nicht alles probieren. Silverlight und irgendwie im Web.
Sie haben Ajax erfunden, das hat versehentlich geklappt.
Ja, das war wohl eher Zufall. Ja, so Ajax, das basiert auf einer ursprünglichen Idee von Microsoft. Das stimmt. Das war auch ihre dynamische Phase, als sie mit ihrem Internet-Explorer. In jedem HTML-Element, was auf deinem Bildschirm ist, wahrscheinlich dreißigmal.
Ach so, ihr meint nicht dieses andere mit A, was wir haben?
Java-Skript. Nein, nein, wir reden einfach von dynamischen Webseiten mit Java-Skript. Wie auch immer. So, aber gut, ich meine, ich rede von Standards, ja. Das war ja etwas, das haben sie dann halt mal irgendwie gemacht und dann haben das alle anderen genauso gemacht, weil das an der Stelle eine gute Idee war. Das ist nicht das, was ich meine. Aber so, früher war es immer so, Microsoft kündigt irgendetwas an und 10 Firmen gehen pleite, weil es irgendwie Vaporware ist so und das Produkt kommt nie.
Und die pure Tatsache, dass es mal kommen könnte, ist...
Genau, oder erinnere dich an diese Debatte mit DVD, mit HD-DVD und Blu-Ray, was jetzt irgendwie vorbei ist.
Stimmt, da haben sie mal so richtig schön gegen jemanden gefahren.
Ja, und damit verbunden natürlich auch ihr Codec-Krieg, dass sie halt VC1 durchsetzen wollten, also im Prinzip...
Dass ein Microsoft-Gerät HA-264 ihn verstützt, ist eigentlich schon der Beweis dafür, dass sie nichts mehr durchsetzen können.
Und das nimmt man schon fast gar nicht mehr wahr. Aber erinner dich, vor zehn Jahren hat jeder zu Microsoft geguckt. Und Apple konnte sich irgendwie strecken, wie sie wollten. Wenn die irgendwie gesagt haben, wir haben hier was Neues erfunden, macht das bitte alle so wie wir.
Das war nicht nur Apple, die sich strecken konnten, wie sie wollten.
Keiner, genau. Also alle hatten ihre Probleme damit. IBM, eigentlich die ganze Branche hat einfach gelitten und Microsoft hat dann vor allem alles immer nur Scheiße gemacht. Und sie haben ja komplette Titanen mit in den Abgrund gezogen. Hier, SGI ist auch an Microsoft zerbrochen. Die Erfinder von OpenGL haben dann mit Microsoft ein Deal gemacht für die zukünftigen 3D-Standard. Komplett über den Tisch gezogen worden. Wer ist letzten Endes daran verreckt, SGI, diese Firma, gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Der 3D-Veteran überhaupt. Was lebt heute wie nix? OpenGL. Man redet nicht mehr von den DirectX-Sachen, redet halt einfach keiner mehr. Das ist natürlich immer noch super mega dominant in der Windows-Welt, aber es spielt außerhalb der Windows-Welt einfach keine Rolle und niemand würde sagen, dass man sich eben die Vorschläge von Microsoft weiter anschauen muss. Bei HTML sind sie mittlerweile komplett abgehängt worden. Sie haben da sicherlich auch ein paar Leute in ihren Gremien, aber es ist nicht so, dass sie irgendetwas nach vorne bringen würden. Das ist der Punkt. Insofern sind wir jetzt einfach an einem Punkt angelangt, wo es schon einfach echt entspannt ist. Jetzt können wir uns einfach nur noch zurücklehnen, ins Sofa drücken und zu gucken, wie sie sich weiter blamieren.
Ich finde es ja, in diesem PDA-Smartphone-Bereich, finde ich es ja eigentlich, es ist ja fast schon so eine Genugtuung. Da war ja Palm, also eigentlich der Newton der Erste, aber Palm der Erste, der wirklich Erfolg hatte. Und dann konnte man ja sehen, wie Microsoft mit diversen Windows-Versionen irgendwann mal tatsächlich einen Fuß in die Tür gekriegt hat, irgendwie mit Windows CE.
Mit diesen iPads.
Genau, und wie sie dann wirklich ja genüsslich...
Von welcher Firma war denn das Ding eigentlich?
iPads? Compaq.
Compaq, genau.
Und dann genüsslich auf Palm rumgetreten haben und den nach und nach immer schön in die Fresse gehauen. Und dann hat ja eigentlich im Endeffekt, jetzt hat Palm, der Kleine, wieder ein halbwegs okayer, so S, mit dem man sagen könnte, ja, damit traut man ihm noch eine Zukunft zu. Wohingegen bei Microsoft ist nun wirklich alles vorbei. Zumindest mit dem OS.
Ist durch. Mobile haben sie verloren. Also das kann man, glaube ich, jetzt einfach mal so festhalten.
Na ja, das ist auch nichts, was...
Die Apple-Jeweler haben jetzt auch wieder eine neue Zählmethode. Das heißt jetzt, dass irgendwie die Home-Based Installation in Amerika bei 12 Prozent liegt, der Mac-User.
Wer hat eine neue Zählmethode?
Die Apple-Fanboys.
Ach, Apple-Fanboys.
Home-Based Installation, das ist aber interessant, 12 Prozent.
Was soll das jetzt sagen? 12 Prozent aller Haushalte haben einen Mac oder was? Oder 12 Prozent aller Haushalte, die einen Computer haben, haben einen Mac, aber haben nicht nur einen Mac, sondern auch einen Mac oder was? Oder haben auch ein Windows?
Ich glaube, das sind einfach von den gesamten Computern alle rausgenommen, die in irgendwelchen Büros stehen.
Ich glaube, das ist eine wackelige Zahl. Aber ich glaube auf jeden Fall, dass der Mac, zumindest in den USA, sicher zweistellig ist und hier ist er vielleicht auf dem besten Weg dazu. Weiß man ja nicht, es gibt ja keine verlässlichen Zahlen.
Ich sehe auch immer nur Mac-User, ich sehe kaum Windows-User.
Ja, so ist das. Und wir haben auch nur Konvertiten.
Aber ich glaube, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil die sich einfach nicht mehr raustrauen. Weil ich meine, mal ehrlich, so Windows, also mit so einem PC-Laptop.
Ja, wir begrüßen dabei auch den Switcher des Tages hier, irgendwie Philipp vom Medienküchen und Bundesradio. Hat sich heute auch einen Wegetausch gekauft.
Ach, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Das war die Andachtsstille. Genau, ich hab jetzt überlegt, wenn wir jetzt eine Minute kriegen, kriegen wir hier nicht zusammen, dann fängt es an zu piepen.
Ist das noch die Panikphase, wo man denkt, ach du Scheiße, was hab ich hier nur gemacht? Ich hab ja leider nix gehört da vorne, aber die ganze Zeit auf ihn eingeredet, er soll dich einen meck kaufen, oder?
Ich hab nicht auf ihn eingeredet.
Hast du so sublime Nachrichten, die du dann verschickst?
Naja, ich hab so meine Bedenken geäußert, ob das so zukunftsfähig ist. Naja, mal gucken. Google Wave, wollen wir was machen?
Mal Google Wave. Vom gefallenen Bösewicht zum aufsteigenden Bösewicht.
Smartphone-Thema haben wir durch. Hab ich erwähnt, dass RIM sich eine Browser-Bude gekauft hat.
Die haben sich eine Browser-Bude gekauft?
Ja, RIM sind doch die einzigen, die nicht WebKit verwenden.
Was wollen die jetzt?
Was nehmen die?
Die haben sich jetzt eine Bude gekauft, die für Blackberry OS einen Webkit-basierten Browser gemacht haben.
Ach, das ist doch mal eine gute Entscheidung.
Mit anderen Worten, jetzt haben sie alle Webkit.
Auch so Microsoft.
Hatten wir nicht gerade das Thema, dass sie nicht mehr da sind?
Ach so.
Nokia bin ich mal gespannt. Memo ja nicht, Memo hat ja mal die Firebox.
Stimmt, bei Memo wollen die ja tatsächlich auf Gecko setzen.
Oh Mann. Bei Gecko wollen ja einen Mobile-Engine machen.
Das haben sie ja sogar schon. Der ist noch in der Entwicklung. Es gibt für Windows Mobile und für Symbian, glaube ich. Und für Android wollen sie ihn rausbringen.
Konkurrenz kann nicht schaden.
Das stimmt.
Nur WebKit, dann geht es auch den Bach runter. Zumindest featuremäßig oder ideenmäßig. Ich finde das schon ganz gut. Auch das Chrome kam hier mit diesem Multistrading. Jedes Fenster ein Multistrad und so. Das ist ganz gut, das feiert den Konkurrenz an.
Jedes Fenster ist ein Prozess.
Ja, so.
Dann kann ich noch etwas zu Chrome erzählen. Ich habe nämlich angefangen, für Chrome ein Plugin zu schreiben. Also eine Erweiterung, so eine native. Die geht ja auch ins JavaScript. Das ist eine Wolke. Das macht echt Laune. Das ist ganz großartig. Ich lad mir regelmäßig diese neuesten Developer-Bills runter von Chromium. Also nicht diese offizielle Version, die sie irgendwann mal vor Ewigkeiten rausgebracht haben, damit alle Ruhe gehen. Und die ist mittlerweile relativ rund. Also ich erwische mich schon öfters mal dabei, mit Chromium mittlerweile zu surfen. Und weil ich gelesen habe, dass es da so unglaublich schön einfach ist, da für Extensions zu entwickeln, hab ich das einfach mal ausprobiert, hab so einen Flashblocker geschrieben, der jetzt noch nicht so das ganz Gelbe vom Eis, aber funktioniert schon ganz kluftig. Und das waren so 20 Zeilen, 30 Zeilen JavaScript Code, und dann hatte ich meinen Flashblocker da fertig und alles schön mit Web-Techniken. Und das ist nun, also für Safari kann man gar keine Erweiterung schreiben. Für Firefox mit diesem ganzen XUL-Zeug und weiß ja toll was, und für jeden Test muss man Firefox neu starten. Beziehungsweise jetzt mittlerweile haben sie ja für Firefox gibt's dieses Jetpack. Das ist so eine Erweiterung für Firefox, mit der man auch für Firefox Erweiterungen in JavaScript schreiben kann.
Eine Erweiterung für Erweiterungen?
Eine Erweiterung für Erweiterungen. Was schon mal ein schicker Ansatz ist, was auf jeden Fall schon mal ein bisschen mehr Spaß macht. Wobei, also ich geh mal davon aus, dass Jetpack dann in Firefox 3.6 oder 3.7 mit drin sein wird und dann kann man da total einfach für Erweiterungen schreiben, die dann auch installierbar sind, ohne dass das Ding neu gestartet werden kann. Chromium bzw. Chrome kann das nativ, da braucht man keine Erweiterungen dafür. Da haben sie eine schöne API definiert, die wirklich Laune macht. Und das macht echt viel Spaß, dafür Erweiterungen zu schreiben. Aber Apple, davon kannst du dir langsam mal eine Scheibe abschneiden, das wäre echt praktisch.
Du meinst, dass sie für Safari eine API öffnen sollen? Tja, sie tun es nicht.
Die denken immer zu geschlossen bei sowas.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, hast du das mit One Password mitbekommen?
Wie die sich jetzt reinhacken müssen in das Safari 64-Bit-Zug?
Ja. Hast du das verstanden? Ich hab das nur so im Ansatz verstanden.
Der Gedanke ist, früher waren alle rein über diese Input-Manager.
Genau, und diese Tür ist jetzt mit 64-Bit zu.
Die gibt's nur für 64-Bit nicht mehr. Darum mussten sie sich eine Alternative suchen.
Und sind jetzt über die Scripting-Filzstelle.
Und gehen jetzt über die Scripting-Editions rein.
Na, das ist doch geil.
Und laden darüber Code nach, aber auch nicht auf die legale Art und Weise. Es ist ja nicht einfach so, als ob sie Apple-Skripte dafür schreiben würden für Safari oder so eine Erweitung.
Offensichtlich muss es ja darüber so weit erweiterbar sein, dass sie über Scripting-Hooks User-Interface-Elemente einblenden können. Das ist doch eigentlich ein wunderbares Interface.
Also wenn ich das verstanden habe, dann ist das... dann nutzen sie eigentlich nur den... also dann ist der Eingang nur ein anderer. Aber die Technik, die sie nachher verwenden, also es geht nur darum, deinen eigenen Code irgendwie...
Sie injecten über ein anderes Loch.
Ja, genau. Ich glaube, die haben einfach nur ein anderes Loch in Safari gefunden. Würde ich jetzt mal behaupten... das ist nicht so für Berlinern... Würde ich jetzt mal behaupten. Und...
Da wüsste mich auf den linken Fuß. Kann ich gerade nicht beantworten. Ich hab dieses Ding überflogen und...
Ich hab noch eine letzte Sache bei Smartphones.
Ja.
Also ich bin ja schon auch ein Fanboy. Also ein Apple-Fanboy. Hab aber... Was war es heute Mittwoch? Vorgestern an so einem Android irgendwie gesessen.
Ja, welchen?
Keine Ahnung, so ein komisches schwarzes Ding.
Aber jetzt nicht dieses G1 mit Google.
Eins, was man glaube ich so seitwärts aufschieben kann, wo unten so ein Stück fest stehen bleibt. Genau. Und da hab ich mal... Wir haben so ein bisschen verglichen hier, weil der ja auch diesen Webkit benutzt und mit dem brausen, wie der das rendert und so darstellt und wie schnell das ist. Also erstens haben wir festgestellt, dass das 3GS erst mal flotter ist. Klar. Also auch grundsätzlich hier so beim Goethe vom Android kannst du ja so auch hin und her ziehen und es ist halt so ein bisschen ruckelig und beim iPhone ist es halt schön butterweich. Ist natürlich auch ein bisschen fies, das 3GS irgendwie zum Vergleich zu nehmen, aber der meinte auch, dass auch bei seinem 3G wäre das auch schon flotschiger.
Egal.
Aber was ich meine, der eigentliche Punkt ist, dass deren Browser, also Chrome, was hat er so? Ja, dass der einen anderen Font hat als der Safari auf dem iPhone. Und zwar fand ich, dass der viel, viel besser aussieht. Also ich glaub, die haben da so einen handverlesenen Font genommen.
Die haben einen eigenen Font dafür entwickelt.
Ja, und ich glaube auch, dass sie den wirklich für alles Mögliche einsetzen. Also ich glaube, die überblenden sozusagen den Standard-Font, den man so hat. Obwohl man hat keinen Standard-Font, oder? Man kann einen Standard-Font definieren, klar. Weiß ich gar nicht.
Die Browser haben ihren eigenen Default. Also es gibt einen Default Suns und einen Suns Serif und einen Default Serif. Aber welcher das ist, ist deine Sache.
Jedenfalls bei dem Chrom, der von sah wesentlich besser aus. Also beim Safari sah man immer so, bei manchen ist der Buchstabe so ein bisschen mehr bold und ist ja wieder ein bisschen dünner, je nachdem wie er das halt auch so reinskalieren muss, weil er das ja stufenlos skalieren kann. Und ich fand bei dem Chrom, das sah einfach, da waren die Buchstaben alle immer gleich groß, gleich dick und auch sehr kontrastreich gut zu lesen. Also ich fand, das sah besser aus.
Das ist aber das erste Positive, was ich in dem Bereich über...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das okay ist oder ob der vielleicht sogar das Standard-Rendering durcheinander bringt oder woanders schummelt. Das könnte gleich sein, dass sie irgendwas hin drehen, was irgendwie nicht so okay ist, um diese Optik hinzukriegen. Also vom Gesamtlayout. Aber so der Font an sich fand ich, der war schicker.
Also gerade den Browser bei Android finde ich um Klassen schlechter als bei Asien Safari auf dem iPhone.
Ich will jetzt also scrollen und Zeug, was die da so für Tricks haben und so.
Dass er automatisch reingezoomt ist, im reingezoomten Modus anfängt. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das hat patentieren lassen. Du kannst so billige Sachen, du kannst, wenn du eine falsche URL eingegeben hast, die nicht gefunden werden konnte, dann konntest du die nicht korrigieren. Man vertippt sich ja gerne mal auf so eine kleine Tastatur und dann hat man da irgendwie eine 50 Zeichen lange URL eingetippt, hat sich an einer Stelle vertippt und man kann eine URL nicht ändern, die man schon eingegeben hat. Auf Android. Also sind es echt so Sachen, wo man sich denkt, ach kommt Leute, das kann doch nicht so schwer sein, das muss doch euch doch bei der Entwicklung aufgefallen sein, dass das scheiße ist. Und es gibt im Store, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schonmal erwähnt hab, es gibt im Android Store kein Update All Button. Also wenn man da neue...
Na guck, den hatte Apfel am Anfang auch nicht.
Ja, sie haben jetzt 1.6 draußen und auch 1.6 hat immer noch nicht diesen Update All Button.
Da war wahrscheinlich noch keiner Developer jemals mehr als zwei Programme update musste, weil da gibt es noch nicht so viele.
Naja, es gibt sehr, sehr viele Updates für Android, weil die nämlich, da kann man ja auch mal in eine andere Richtung ein bisschen schießen, weil die irgendwie nicht alle in so einen dreimonatigen Prozess bei Google rein müssen, ob sie dann in den Store auch laufen dürfen, darum gibt es relativ viele Updates. Und dafür wäre ein Update All Button schon mal was OKes. Also irgendwie ist das bei Android so ein bisschen, ja...
Ok, jetzt sind wir glaube ich fertig mit Smartphones.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man das jetzt noch abrunden wollt... Naja, also die letzten Zahlen war ja auch ganz interessant.
Welche?
Smartphone Markt.
Und da gab es auch irgendwas, ne?
Die neueste Geschichte ist irgendwie aus dem August so. Und so in EMEA hat sich irgendwie Apple jetzt auch schon an Platz 2 gesetzt. Also EMEA ist Europe, Middle East, Asia. Und da sieht es so aus, dass Nokia da bei 64% der Shipments ist, runter von 71%, also innerhalb eines Jahres. Also da haben sie irgendwie mal wieder ein paar Prozente abgegeben. Und Apple ist aber schon auf Platz 2 mit einem Rimm.
Und jetzt die Lottozahlen von letzter Woche.
Und vor allem alles geht irgendwie auf Touchscreen. Also wo sie am Anfang immer noch meinten, mein Gott, das hat ja keine Tastatur. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an die Sache mit dem iMac. Oh Gott, er hat keine floppy disk. Und ja, in Nordamerika gibt es kein Nokia mehr. Oder gab es nie. Und gibt es jetzt auch immer noch nicht. Und wird es wahrscheinlich nie mehr geben. So, RIM ist da irgendwie noch auf Platz 1. Aber auch da marschiert Apple voran. Und nach OS sind jetzt immer, also die Änderungen sind jetzt immer auf ein Jahr bezogen. Das bezieht sich jetzt aufs zweite Quartal, also dritte Quartal, weiß ich nicht, ob die Zahlen schon draußen sind. Ich glaube noch nicht. Symbian ist mittlerweile innerhalb eines Jahres von 58% auf 50% gefallen, also Globally. Und RIM hat da Zuwachsraten, wahrscheinlich vor allem ihrem starken Auftreten in Nordamerika geschuldet. Na ja, und Apple, ja gut, hat da irgendwie massiv Zuwachs gehabt. Microsoft ist runter auf 9%. Das ist also sozusagen der reale, tatsächliche Shipment-Anteil Market-Share von Microsoft. Runter von 14%, also quasi 30% weniger, sonst knapp 28, um genau zu sein. Ja, und 39% verwenden mittlerweile Touchscreen. Also mehr als Keypad. Okay, ist ein bisschen verwirrend. Sie unterscheiden zwischen Touchscreen, Keypad und Keyboard.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Keypad und Keyboard?
Na Keyboard wird wahrscheinlich so eine kleine QWERTY-Tastatur sein und Keypad wird wahrscheinlich einfach ein 10er-Block sein. Also so ein normaler Telefonblock.
Zählt das überhaupt noch als Smartphone dann?
Das stimmt doch noch irgendwo.
Naja, die Frage ist, was würdest du sagen, so ein E61? Ist das ein Keyboard oder ein Keypad?
Weiß jetzt gar nicht, was das E61 ist.
Naja, also dieses hässliche...
Dieses riesen Teil, was du da mitnimmst, das hatte doch eine richtige Tastatur.
N97.
Ja, aber es ist eine richtige Tastatur.
Jeder Buchstabe 1 ist eine richtige Tastatur.
Aber das N97 zum Beispiel ist ein Smartphone eindeutig und hat keine Tastatur. Sondern nur Zahlenblock. Überhaupt diverse Nokia-Telefone.
Und das geht?
Sowas gibt es. Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, Touchscreen ist jetzt schon bei 40% und hat irgendwie halt vier-, dreifache Zuwachsraten. So sieht es nämlich aus. Gut, Smartphones dicht. Wollen wir jetzt über Wave reden?
Ja.
Wir haben schon mal über Wave geredet.
Wir haben schon mal über Wave geredet. Vor langer, langer, langer Zeit. Damals, als wir es vorgeführt haben und wir alle gedacht haben, oh mein Gott, das würde ich auch an der Stelle haben. Oder? Das war so...
Ich will das auch immer noch haben. Ich bin auch sehr froh, dass ich das jetzt habe. Weil das einfach mal geil ist.
Ich finde ja die Rollbalken echt schick.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Die finde ich ein bisschen verstörend.
Also für alle, die es noch nicht haben, das sind... Also die haben sich platzsparende Rollbalken ausgedacht.
Müssen wir das nochmal erklären, was Google Wave ist?
Jetzt gehen wir nochmal in die Herstellung. Das ist vielleicht ganz gut, das nochmal ein bisschen vorneweg zu erzählen. Willst du anfangen?
Kann ich machen.
Es war einmal eine Welle.
Es war einmal Instant Messaging. Und aus Instant Messaging ist jetzt Google Wave geworden. Also Google hat XMPP genommen oder auch Java. Also das, worauf ihr Google Talk basiert. Und auch das, was iChat kann. Auch wenn iChat mal mit IEM angefangen hat, kann es jetzt genauso auch Java machen. Und es hat schon immer Java gemacht. Wenn man zum Beispiel über Bonjour im lokalen Netz iChat-Chat gemacht hat, dann war das auch schon immer Java. Noch bevor sie richtige Java-Server unterstützt haben. Naja, und XMPP steht ja für Extensible Messaging-Protokoll. Und das haben sie jetzt halt getan. Das Ganze basiert, also wenn man sich selber das installieren will, dann muss man sich dieses OpenFire schnappen. Das ist so ein Java-Server, wo man halt Plugins installieren kann. Und das Google Wave kommt quasi so als Plugin. Also wer da wirklich Lust hat, sich auch selber eine eigene Wave-Infrastruktur aufzubauen, da gibt's eben von Google auch Code.
Da hätte ich erst Lust zu, weil die offizielle zurzeit ziemlich langsam ist, muss man mal sagen. Deutlich überlastet. Obwohl ihr habt gerade wieder super zu gehen.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass einfach die ganze Welt darauf rumklickt und ausprobiert, wie denn das mal so ist. Sie haben da eh schon so einen Throttle drin gehabt, aber ich muss sagen, so wie es funktioniert, das war so in etwa das, was ich erwartet hatte. Also das war so, wie sie es präsentiert haben. So präsentiert sich das jetzt auch. Es ist halt, sagen wir mal jetzt vom Look und Feel her, nicht so sehr viel anders als Gmail. Es tut bloß was anderes.
Na, die offizielle, die Marketing spreche für, was es Wave von Google ist. Wave ist das, was Mail wäre, wenn sie nicht vor 40 Jahren, sondern heute erfunden werden würde. Ja, also es fängt damit an, dass es, also man kann, der Demo basiert ja darauf, die haben angefangen, haben so eine Wave angelegt und haben gesagt, du siehst erstmal wie eine Mail. Und dann kannst du da Empfänger hinzufügen. Der einzige Unterschied ist, dass wenn jemand das bekommt, kann er auch schön replyen und du siehst das direkt unter der Mail. Und alles okay, aber man kann auch einfach direkt wieder ins Originaldokument reintippen und dran rumeditieren und man kann Änderungen nachverfolgen. Alles in Live, wirklich in Echtzeit. Ich kann jetzt hier gerade sehen, wie der halbe Chat vor sich hin tippt in diesem Google Wave Dokument. Es ist schon alles sehr sehr sexy, was sie haben.
In welchem Dokument?
Irgendjemand hat hier im Chat so einen Link gepostet. Du bist da auch mit drin.
Du meinst der super Einstieg in MM?
Genau, der super Einstieg in MM.
Alle Leute, die Wave haben, waven jetzt hier sozusagen auch schon. Es gibt übrigens auch Public Waves. Also man kann auch wirklich explizit sagen, wie ist das irgendwie? Du Doppelpunkt Public oder so. Und dann kriegst du irgendwie so Public Waves, die sozusagen öffentliche Waves sind, wo jeder jederzeit joinen kann. Aber grundsätzlich hat man einfach Threaded Communication gespeichert in so einem Metaobjekt eben in dieser Wave. Ein Wave Server hält diese Wave vor und der einzige wirkliche Wave-Anbieter derzeit ist natürlich Google, ist ja klar, weil die haben das nun gerade mal erfunden und bauen das jetzt auf und werden wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Weile lang alleine sein. Ich könnte mir aber durchaus vorstellen, dass das nicht sehr lange auf sich warten lässt, dass eben auch andere anfangen, sich Wave-Instanzen zu besorgen, insbesondere für Firmen, die das wirklich produktiv einsetzen wollen, die aber also sagen wir mal so ein gewisses Sicherheitsgefühl erhalten möchten und eben nicht ihre Kommunikation über Google laufen lassen. Das wird man sehen. Ich finde das ganze super vielversprechend, insbesondere über diese ganzen Extensions, die sich dort entwickelt werden. Weil in dem Moment, wo einfach, jetzt gibt es ja jetzt schon sowas wie einfaches Voting und Bim-Bim, aber es gibt auch Video-Chat und so eine Sachen. Das wird einfach ein sehr viel interaktiveres Kommunizieren. Und ich denke, sie müssen hier noch so einiges machen, weil wenn man hier, wenn einem die Wave-Inbox voll läuft, dann hat man da irgendwie genauso wenig Überblick wie in seinem Mail-Programm. Aber immerhin, eine Zeile da drin ist eben nicht eine Nachricht, die ein Ausschnitt aus einer Diskussion ist, sondern jede Wave ist halt die vollständige Diskussion komplett mit allem hin und her, mit seiner ganzen Historie. Man kann oben an diesem Slider ziehen und ganz zur Entstehungsgeschichte an den Anfang der Wave gehen und dann einfach nach vorne spielen und man sieht, wie sich das irgendwie abspielt.
Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, wenn das erste Mal irgendwie ein großer Skandal auffliegt, weil ein Ministerium nicht gepeilt hat, dass jeder, den man jetzt gerade hinzugefügt hat, einfach mal eine Stufe zurückscrollen kann und sehen kann, wie die Zahlen in letzter Sekunde noch manipuliert worden sind. Wie es ja bei Word-Dokumentenregeln immer passiert ist.
Obwohl das ein riesen Vorteil ist, ist das hier auch eine der verwirrenden Sachen.
Definitiv.
Dass also etwas, was oben schon irgendwann mal stand, geändert werden kann und man sieht ja jetzt nicht jede Änderung sofort. Und man spielt ja auch nicht unbedingt immer alles ab. Also dieses Verfolgen einer solchen Kommunikation. Ich denke mal, da werden sich noch so Sachen einbürgern, dass so eine Wave explizit zum Editieren freigegeben werden muss von dem Autor oder dass ein Beitrag explizit freigegeben werden darf. Kann nicht sein, dass jetzt jemand in meinem Beitrag rumeditiert. Wo kommen wir denn dahin? Dann landen wir vielleicht bei der Wikipedia.
Ja.
tja, also wer jetzt beleidigt ist, weil er jetzt diesen Zeitpunkt, wo er das hört, noch selber keinen Invite bekommen hat und das man auch ausprobieren will. Zu Recht. Es ist interessant. Es ist jetzt aber auch nicht so, dass man jetzt gleich stirbt, wenn man keinen hat. Ich persönlich wollte das schon immer mal haben. Und ich bin vor allem gespannt, wie sehr sich das für Planung nutzt. Also für uns ist das eigentlich ein Geschenk. Gerade so für unser Problem, dass wir irgendwie so etwas Wikiatiges brauchen und dass man aber irgendwie auch da die ganze Kommunikation drin haben will. Jetzt würden wir für jede Sendung einfach eine neue Wave aufmachen. Hätten dann am Anfang unsere Timeline drin. Jeder hat seine Links und man kann auch genau sehen, wie das irgendwie alles entstanden ist. Und man kann darüber hinaus auch noch über den Termin genau diskutieren und so weiter.
Man könnte das noch viel weiter machen. Man könnte eigentlich sozusagen da die ganzen... Also in der Demo, und das gibt's ja auch diese Robots, die sie dafür haben, also diese Erweiterbarkeiten, eine von den vielen, besteht ja auch darin, man könnte das ja direkt machen. Wir nehmen vorher unseren Notiz-Zettel, basteln das Ganze, dann irgendwann schmeißen wir mal, arbeiten das ab in der Sendung, bringen das in die richtige Reihenfolge, dann packen wir den Publizierer jetzt mal in unseren Blog-Robot rein. Und dann wäre das ein Blog-Artikel bei Mobile Max. Und die Kommentare, die dann reinkommen, die würden dann als Replies kommen. Und dann könnte man direkt über seine Inbox quasi...
Also diese Robots sind natürlich auch eine echte Gefahr, weil wenn du damit erstmal zu weit voranschreitest, dann weißt du irgendwann überhaupt nicht mehr, welcher Teil deiner Kommunikation öffentlich ist und was nicht öffentlich ist. Da wären die Leute glaube ich noch sehr viel eher als jetzt hier diese Szenario, was du eben gemacht hast, gegen die Wand fahren. Das ist einfach irgendwas tippen und glauben, es wäre eine private Kommunikation und im Hintergrund wurstelt irgendwo so ein Bot und wirft das auf Twitter.
Ich glaube, es wird, ja also das wird natürlich passieren, es wird aber auch massenhaft passieren. Ja, ja, das habe ich doch schon vorgestern gemacht, dann kann man dem Datum genau ansehen, dass sie das erst vor 3 Minuten gemacht haben, die Änderung. Ähm, so was, also es wird noch weniger Geheimnisse geben voreinander.
Da bist du wieder mit deiner grunddeutschen Mentalität, dass man irgendwie so eine neue Technologie erstmal darüber nachdenkt, was man alles Schlimmes damit ansteckt.
Nee, ich möchte über beide Sachen nachdenken, über die guten und über die schlechten Sachen.
Genau, das ist die deutsche Mentalität. Amerikaner machen sich nur darüber Gedanken, wie man coole Sachen mitmachen kann.
Und dann haben sie Abokorep.
Was?
War ein schlechter Witz.
Ja, also was haben wir schon.
Nein, schneid, schneid, schneid. Wir wissen es bloß nicht. Aber ich find die Rollbalken echt schick.
Ich find die furchtbar.
Nee, da wirst du dich noch so schnell dran gewöhnen.
Daran soll ich mich gewöhnen, ich seh nie, wie lang dieses Dokument ist. What's wrong with the original Scrollbar?
Natürlich siehst du, wie lang das Dokument ist. Und zwar daran, dass...
An diesen kleinen mini halbdurchsichtigen Grauelementchen, was da irgendwo an der Seite dran klebt.
Genau.
Es werden ja auch wieder ändern. Die probieren es jetzt, sagen alles Scheiße außer Max. Und dann machen sie es wieder weg.
Ja, für dich gibt es ein eigenes Google Wave, wo sie diesen Scrollbar beibehalten.
Der nimmt einfach nicht so unglaublich viel Platz weg, wie dieser anderen. Also erst mal nutzt ihr heutzutage sowieso keine sauberen Scrollbalken.
Ich nutze meinen Finger, genau.
Man macht das über zwei Finger Scrolling. Insofern geht das auch super bei Google Wave. Man sieht, wo ist immer noch ein Dokument.
Bei Scrollbar gibt es ja sofort einen Eindruck davon, wie groß eine Liste ist. Und das sehe ich hier einfach nicht.
Weil er immer gleich groß ist.
Der einzige Unterschied, wo du das siehst, ist dieses kleine Teil, was da irgendwo dran klebt, als hätte der Programmierer es an die falsche Stelle gesehen.
Auf dem iPhone siehst du auch nicht, wie weit du da scrollen kannst. Erst deine Scrolls kommen, die durchsichtigen Scrollteile.
Ja, aber dann sehe ich dem Teil schon an, wie groß das relativ ist.
Ja, dann schon.
Ja, aber hier nicht. Hier muss ich gucken, wo dieses Ding ist. Also das ist, weiß ich nicht...
Ich finde das, ich finde das, also es nimmt einfach so ein blöder Rollbalken, den keiner so anklickt, der nimmt da 16 mal eine Bildschirmhohe weg. Pixel auf dem Bildschirm.
Wie viele Leute sind denn jetzt in dieser Wave? Kann man das überhaupt sehen, wie viele da drin sind?
Das sind 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Ach so, nur diese 7? Ach so, ich dachte, das wären noch mehr.
Hm, TuneBase FM, den ich jetzt gerade hinzufügen wollte, hat gesagt, dass er keinen Google-Welfe-Count hat.
Aber wie kann man die denn jetzt, was ich noch nicht verstanden habe, ist, wie man das Ding jetzt irgendwie public macht. Man muss das irgendwie, man muss glaube ich so ein public... Jetzt schreibst du nicht, was, bist du das? Was? Schreib den hier. Achso, das ist Dom.
Genau.
So, so. Der schreibt mir jetzt live mit, ich werd live transkribiert. In meinem eigenen Browser-Fenster.
Und wer tippt mich jetzt gefälligst mit?
Ach ja, das ist super. So Jungs, wie lange machen wir denn jetzt hier eigentlich schon wieder Sendung? Noch nicht so lange. Krass. Aber vielleicht treiben wir es heute mal nicht so hart. Ich bin ganz schön... Dann haben wir noch was wichtiges. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch eine ganze Menge Sachen, die ich schon immer mal erwähnen wollte, aber ich glaube, ich werde wieder nicht dazu kommen.
Also ich hab, was ich habe...
Du hast ja noch 1000 Sachen.
Ne? Also was ich ja noch habe, ist...
Jetzt müssen wir einfach mal hier über diese Upstore-Geschichte... Ist das jetzt eigentlich schon der Flash? Der ist doch bestimmt im Chat, oder? Der Flash. Sag doch mal... Ist denn das mit deinem... Ist denn das mit deinem Upstore-Kram durch? Weißt du, was ich meine?
Ich weiß, was du meinst.
Der Flash hat diese Rums-Ding.
Ein wichtiges Thema hab ich noch.
Die Rums-Applikation. Die wird seit 4 Monaten nicht aktualisiert, weil es irgendwie ewig hin und her geht.
Was ist denn das Problem?
Das Problem ist sehr vielschichtig und weil es so vielschichtig ist, hat er da auch einen längeren Blog-Eintrag dazu gemacht. Er meint gerade, es sei immer noch alles beim Alten, beziehungsweise es sei immer noch schlimmer geworden.
Ach du Scheiße.
War er ja.
Wurde er jetzt schon verfolgt oder was?
Ja, es haben ihn sogar schon Leute angerufen. Wahrscheinlich mit einem schwarzen Hubschrauber auf seinem Hintergrund gelandet.
Was ist denn an seinem Programm jetzt so evil?
Tja, wenn ich das jetzt mal alles... Flash, gib mir nochmal die URL bitte.
Also ihr merkt, wir sind ja total live.
Wir sind total live, genau. So, hier ist irgendwie die URL im Chat. Roomsapp.mobi, das ist ja mal ein Domain. Genau so, und da gibt es einen Blog und da gibt es diesen schönen Eintrag. Crazy App Update Diary. So, wo er sozusagen diese ganze Update-Geschichte beschreibt und sie fängt an am 25. Mai 2009. Seitdem versucht er irgendwie ein Update. Wo? Na, der vorletzte Eintritt, die letzte URL im Chat. Oh, ich bin ja im falschen Stück. Genau, im Wesentlichen war es irgendwie so ein Bug, der eigentlich irgendwie bei Apple lag und so weiter. Eigentlich müsste der Flash, der will ja hier nicht in die Sendung kommen. Wir können uns das mal so schon erklären. Ist doch egal. Flash. Willst du es nicht mal selber erzählen, die Geschichte? Also wir werden jetzt einfach mal eine Geschichte linken. Ja, geht das jetzt alles nicht zusammen. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine unglaubliche Saga, die jetzt irgendwie seit vier Monaten immer noch nicht aktualisiert wurde. Und das Ganze basiert auf einem Bug, der im iPhone 3.1 auch immer noch nicht behoben wurde. Also sozusagen ein Bug im OS führt dazu, dass sein Programm nicht angenommen wird. Die wollen es irgendwie nicht glauben oder wollen was weiß ich nicht wahrhaben.
Wie, was? Aber ich meine, hat er kein Workaround für den Bug? Oder was?
Ich dir das jetzt alles so genau erklären könnte. Du hast aber doch diese Seite auch vor deiner Nase. Ich bin jetzt einfach schon zu müde.
Ach du bist schon zu müde.
Ja, ich bin durch.
Vielleicht kannst du dich ja, Dennis, mal kurz reinlesen und ich erzähle so lange noch so ein paar andere Geschichten von Halbstar. Also erstmal gibt es da diesen, was ein bisschen Wellen geschlagen hat, ist dieser Taschenrechner. Er hat ja irgendwann so ein Taschenrechnerprogramm geschrieben, wie ihr vielleicht mitbekommen habt. So ein erweiterter wissenschaftlicher Taschenrechner. Und nun kann man ja, wenn man, kennt ihr bestimmt auch noch aus der Schule, wenn man so bestimmte Zahlen da eintippt, in der Taschenrechner so umdreht, dann steht da zum Beispiel plötzlich Liebe. Amerikanische Schüler sind da ganz anderer Natur. Und bei denen kommen dann so Begriffe wie Boobies raus. Heißt das so? Und darum haben die eine Funktion eingebaut. Ich muss jetzt Readout machen. Der Dennis hat seine Valve abstürzen lassen. Und darum haben...
Ist doch egal.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, wenn man das Programm auf den Kopf stellt, also wenn man das iPhone auf den Kopf stellt, um, damit da Boobies stehen könnte, blenden die dann den Spruch zensiert ein. Damit man im App Store nicht abgelehnt wird. Weil es könnte ja ansonsten passieren, dass ein schlauer App Store-Checker nachguckt, wenn ich hier diese Zahl eingebe und das umdrehe, dann steht da Titten und das kann man dem amerikanischen Schüler nicht zumuten, dass er eine Zahl eintippt und dann steht plötzlich auf dem Kopf versehentlich Titten.
Ist das jetzt ernst gemeint?
Das ist ein schicker Marketinggag, wie man schön an einem App Store vorbeikommt. Was ernst gemeint ist, dass Apple ein Programm abgelehnt hat, weil es zu politisch ist mit der offiziellen Begründung. Und zwar geht es da um diese Gesundheitsreform in Amerika, die ja nun deswegen Obama als Hitler und Sozialistin einbezeichnet wird, weil es wagt, jedem Amerikaner eine Gesundheitsversorgung zur Verfügung stellen zu wollen. Und mit diesem App kann man sich angucken, welche Senatoren eigentlich von welcher Gesundheitslobby-Organisation wie viel Geld bekommen haben. Und das Programm hat Apple abgelehnt, weil das ja zu politisch befrachtet ist.
Politically Charged heißt das glaube ich.
Was jetzt das Problem daran ist, dass natürlich massenhaft Politically Charged-Apps im App-Store sind, dass es eine offizielle Obama-App gibt. Jeder zweite Senator hat seine App. Jetzt ist die Hoffnung, dass man das darüber hinkriegt, indem sich ein Senator offiziell sagt, ja, das ist meine App, dass es darüber wiederum reinkommt. Wenn Politik von den offiziellen politischen Kräften im Land betrieben wird, dann ist auch politisch wieder okay. Auf jeden Fall nach tausenden dämlichen Ablehnungsgründen im App-Store ist jetzt noch ein weiterer hinzugekommen. Das finde ich echt...
Ich kann mich nicht so richtig aufregen darüber.
Du kannst dich nicht aufregen darüber?
Nee, das nimmt alles zu viel Raum.
Hast du aufregen? Hast du dieses Flash-Ding mal ein bisschen gelesen?
Nein, das ist ein zehn Seiten langer Log-Eintrag. Das kriege ich jetzt nicht gelesen, ich bin durch.
Du bist durch?
Ja, wenn wir jetzt kein spannendes Thema mehr haben.
Ich habe noch ein sehr spannendes Thema. Warum hat Apple einen Mapping-Dienst gekauft?
Haben sie oder wird es noch gerüchtet?
Die haben es.
Die haben die Leute eingestellt.
Schon schon eine ganze Weile, die haben einen kompletten Dienst gekauft.
Ja, ist doch klar, die wollen Google-los werden. Wer will nicht Google-los werden?
Leute, das ist kein Mapping-Dienst.
Sondern?
Das ist eine Place-Base. So heißt der Laden auch. Das ist ein Dienst, der Orte verwaltet, keine Maps. Die Maps sind völlig egal, es geht um Orte.
Nee, die haben auch eigene Karten.
Shoot out, yeah, ich hol schon das Popcorn.
Was für eigene Karten haben die? Aus welcher Basis?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, die werden sich irgendwie zusammen lizensiert haben.
Ja, das macht Google auch, das wäre kein großer Unterschied. Ja, es ist eine Konkurrenz zu Google. Nein, es ist keine Konkurrenz zu Google, es wäre eine Konkurrenz zu Teleatlas.
Vielleicht kaufen sie die Karten jetzt selber und können da selber Werbung reinmachen und Zeug und vielleicht hatten sie keinen Bock auf Google.
Werbung könnten sie auch selber reinmachen, wenn sie denn wollen würden, aber...
Aber das wär Google, die da die Werbung reinmachen, oder?
Tim verweigert sich. Nein, ich hab das nur so am Rande mitbekommen, aber soweit ich das verstanden habe, ist einfach der eigentliche Clou bei diesem Projekt nicht, dass sie irgendwelche Karten haben, sondern dass sie einfach eine Menge Wissen über Orte. Dass sie einfach eine besonders intelligente Datenbank haben an Geoinformationen. Dabei geht es weniger um die Karten, als eher um die Metadaten.
Nee, das ist eine White Label Mapping Plattform, zum Beispiel, Hanse. Du kriegst Kartenmaterial geliefert und kannst dann eigene Ebenen drüber legen mit eigenen Informationen. Also du kannst zum Beispiel jetzt eine Berlin-Karte, die kriegst du von denen geliefert, du kriegst die AP dafür geliefert und dann kannst du in die Berlin-Karte reinpacken, wo Tim gleich einpennt. Und sowas in der Richtung bietet Google natürlich auch. Die haben auch eine Web-AP, ähnlich wie Google. Die haben eine Menge Dinge, die sehr, sehr ähnlich sind wie bei Google Maps. Und das ist jetzt halt Apple.
Da können wir jetzt natürlich drüber rätseln, was das jetzt zu bedeuten hat. Hast du eine klare Theorie? Sie werden nicht Google Maps abschaffen. Das kann ich dir schon mal sagen.
Warum nicht?
Im iPhone? Warum sollten sie das tun?
Weil sie nichts mehr mit Google zu tun haben wollen.
Warum sollten sie nichts mehr mit Google zu tun haben wollen?
Weil Google ihnen gerade ein Konkurrenzbetriebssystem vorsetzt.
Was hat denn Maps mit dem Konkurrenzbetriebssystem zu tun?
Hast du eine bessere Theorie?
Ich glaube, dass Google und Apple sehr wohl immer noch eigentlich mehr gemeinsame Interessen haben als Konfliktpotenzial. Und von daher kommen die ganz gut miteinander klar.
Dann muss es einen anderen Grund haben.
Die kaufen sich halt gute Leute ein. Ich meine, gut, das war das, was die vorher gemacht haben. Aber ob dieses Produkt jetzt als solches wirklich genau so bei Apple kommen wird, wie das da ursprünglich mal als Business gedacht war, das wage ich zu bezweifeln, weiß ich allerdings auch nicht. Deswegen will ich hier auch gar nicht groß rumspekulieren. Sehr häufig war es einfach so, dass sie solche Start-ups gekauft haben, um einfach an die Leute ranzukommen, weil die einfach cool sind und gute Sachen machen kann. Dass Apple drauf und dran ist, weitere Dienstleistungen anzubieten, zeigt auch dieser Bau dieses neuen Data Centers, was sie da in die Wüste setzen, was wohl riesig ist. Richtig, richtig groß. Services sind auf jeden Fall ein Thema für sie.
Ich hab eine Theorie, was sie machen wollen. Navigations-App. Also ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer, ob das Material von denen dafür taugt. Das ist jetzt wirklich so eine Blöpp, einfach nur, weil mir gerade nichts besseres einfällt. Aber Navigations-App direkt im Betriebssystem ist definitiv ein Markt, würde ich sagen. Man könnte das iPhone nochmal schön aufwerten. Dafür könnte es auch durchaus einen Kompass haben, neben vielen anderen Features.
Glaub ich nicht. Ich glaub auch nicht, dass sie da irgendwie... Warum sollten sie mit TomTom da irgendwie mithalten wollen?
Weil die ab so teuer sind.
Wieso? Wie teuer?
Was kostet TomTom im App Store?
Das ist doch Apple egal. Die Frage ist, ob das für sie ein nennenswerter Markt ist. Ich glaub nicht, dass das unbedingt notwendig ist.
Dass sie ein Telefon drin haben? Nokia wirkt sehr fett damit, dass sie eine Maps-Applikation haben.
Hilft's? Offensichtlich nicht.
Ich glaub schon.
Na, Apple hat zwei, die du kaufen kannst. Daran verdienen die irgendwie 30% mit. Warum sollten sie sich da jetzt noch groß den Stress geben?
Um es vernünftig zu machen zum einen.
Ich finde TomTom ist super. Ich hab mir gerade einen TomTom-Navigationscomputer gekauft für mein Autochin und ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt, wie gut das funktioniert. Ich bin auch manchmal beeindruckt, wie schlecht das funktioniert.
Wäre es nicht besser, wenn du es richtig gut in einem iPhone drin hättest? Es geht doch nicht darum, dass du dir ein extra Gerät hinpappst, wenn du noch ein iPhone in der Tasche hast.
Was ist denn richtig gut? Weißt du, warum TomTom richtig gut ist, weil sie mit Vodafone zusammenarbeiten? Sondern?
Schlecht.
Also ich äh...
Du fässt mal gar nicht Auto.
Na ich hab das auf meinem Moped.
Und was funktioniert da falsch? Also was ist schlecht?
Das funktioniert schon, aber hat so Features, die glaube ich sogar andere haben und TomTom hat es einfach nicht. Zum Beispiel, dass ich sage, bevor ich losfahre, wenn ich gar nicht nach Navi fahren will, aber wenn ich ihm sagen will, also ich fahre sozusagen, wie sagt man, nicht nach Kür, sondern nach Freestyle, also einfach so wie ich fahren will, nicht wie TomTom sagt, und dass ich dem sage, schneide mal mit, das kann das Ding nicht. Und das ist jetzt nicht schlecht, das TomTom Ding funktioniert schon so, aber es ist alles nicht schick und nicht schön und tausend Buttons, Menüs und Zeug und also total überladen, anstatt sich auf die, auf das Wichtige zu konzentrieren.
Kann ich so nicht bestätigen.
Also ich finde halt, im Auto hat man wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit zum Klicken auf dem Motorrad, das kannst du nicht während der Fahrt tausend Klicks.
Es geht nicht so sehr ums Klicken, sondern es geht mir mehr darum, wie gut die Daten sind, die sie haben, vom Verkehr. Ich weiß nicht, hatten wir das hier nicht schonmal besprochen? Ich glaube, das hatten wir vor Uhrzeiten, war ich mal auf der IFA, vor dem JAHNE. Dass sie im Prinzip den kompletten GSM-Traffic von wo davon auswerten, um rauszukriegen, wo gerade Stau ist und wo nicht.
Genau.
Damit haben sie sozusagen so eine tagesaktuelle Bewertung.
Ich sag ja gar nicht, dass TomTom schlecht ist. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Apple das aus Apples Perspektive besser machen kann.
Okay, lassen wir das offen. Ich sag dir, Apple baut keine Navigationssoftware. Das ist nichts, womit sie sich groß rum ärgern werden. Das ist viel zu speziell. Da brauchst du ein riesen Team, das sich nur da mit beschäftigt, was weltweit Karten sammeln muss. Das ist einfach nicht Apples Business. Apples Business ist Plattform, Rechner. Das ist das. Sie müssen keine Navigationssoftware verkaufen, wenn sie auch andere Navigationssoftware verkaufen können. Das ist für sie überhaupt nicht wichtig. Die machen andere Sachen.
Wofür haben sie denn den Sinkauf gekauft?
Weil sie natürlich Geoinformation intelligent anbieten wollen. Ich bezweifle bloß, dass es sich dabei um Autonavigation handelt. Das wird irgendwas sein. Ich kann es dir nicht sagen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was Sie da im Schilde führen. Aber es ist doch schön, wenn Sie Leute finden, die sich innovativ mit neuen Sachen auseinandersetzen.
Tim ist bockig, glaube ich. Ich bin bockig. Der muss ins Bett.
Ich muss definitiv ins Bett.
Haben wir noch Themen?
Tim ist müde und muss ins Bett.
Ich habe per Akklamation keine Themen mehr. Wir müssen auch mal eine Sendung machen, die unter zwei Stunden landet. Nee, haben wir schon überschritten. Unter drei ist auch nicht schlecht. Es wird einfach noch was raus.
Das war's dann.
Noch Schluss machen? Sonst wird das immer so schlechte Unterhaltung.
Glaubst du keine News noch jetzt, kurzfristig, die letzten Tage, irgendwas?
Die letzten Sekunden?
Die Leute wollen doch zum Beispiel Tablet-News schauen. Gibt es da nicht was?
Tablet-News? Es gibt keine Tablet-News.
Nicht?
Ja, schön fand ich dieses Zitat von Steve Jobs, der irgendwie immer wieder gemeint haben soll, dass ihm doch endlich mal jemand erklären soll, wofür dein Tablet noch gut wäre, außer im Bett zu surfen.
Und zum Zocken.
Ich hab so eine ähnliche Frage letztes Mal, als wir das Tablett gestritten haben, auch gestellt. Wozu?
Ich sag nicht, dass ich nicht daran arbeite. Und ich finde auch die Gerüchtelage verdient sich mittlerweile auf eine Art und Weise, wo es sehr wohl sein kann, dass sie auf so was gekommen sind. Aber ich glaube, ja, das war mit dem iPhone auch so. Das ging einfach nicht weg. Und das Gerücht. Trotzdem stellt sich mir einfach die Frage, was nicht heißt, dass es nicht kommt. Aber wenn es kommt, stellt sich mir wirklich die Frage, wie ist es positioniert? Ich glaube fest daran, dass es im Wesentlichen ein großes iPhone ist. Also da wird nicht Mac OS laufen, sondern das wird iPhone OS sein. Das ist, glaube ich, vollkommen klar und wird irgendwie größer sein. Und man kann sich im Wesentlichen schon vorstellen, wie es funktioniert, indem man sich heute einfach ein iPhone anschaut.
Ein iPhone Touch in groß.
Genau, und dann wird es Applikationen geben, die dafür dann speziell natürlich targeten müssen, die sagen müssen, wir unterstützen diese Plattform halt auch. So und dann kannst du es über den App Store, kannst halt die Applikationen auch dafür kaufen. Und ob die iPhone Applikationen da irgendwie einen schnellen Modus finden, da zu laufen, keine Ahnung.
Kommt an, wenn die Auflösung zum Beispiel doppelt so groß ist, dann könnten die da einfach so ein Emulationsding machen, indem sie die Auflösung...
Ich glaube, das werden sie einfach nicht tun. Das werden sie einfach nicht tun. Das wäre einfach nicht ihr Ding, weil dann würde sich ja keiner mehr drum scheren, das irgendwie richtig schick zu machen. Und sie müssen schon auf irgendwas hinaus. Also es muss schon irgendeine Anwendung geben, die wirklich erschlagend ist.
So die Killer-Applikation, dass alle wieder das haben wollen, obwohl sie es nicht brauchen, meinst du?
Ja, ich meine, die berechtigte Frage ist wirklich, was ist zwischen dem Telefon und dem Computer? Und jetzt kommen wir nicht mit, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das vielleicht da und dafür zu benutzen. Das ist wie mit diesen Netbooks, die werden auch am laufenden Meter gekauft, aber keiner benutzt sie.
Meine Rede, dass die Kinder braucht.
Aber wie wäre es denn mit der perfekten Surfmaschine einfach? Surfen ist ein Bereich, der nun wirklich langsam mal wichtig, also lang schon wichtig genug ist.
Als E-Book-Reader. Aber dazu bräuchten sie halt so ein ordentliches Display, da ist das Ding zu schnell leer.
Ein schnelles, also ein OKA-Akku, ein schneller Prozessor, ein großes Display, Mobile Safari mit Tabs und ähm...
Ja, der macht schon seine Tabs, dann kannst du eh nichts mehr sehen, weil dir alles voll wäre mit den Dingern.
Du bist glaube ich der einzige Mensch auf diesem Planeten, der keine Tabs nutzt.
Tabs werden sie da ja auch nicht drauf haben.
Ich glaube nicht mal Apple ist wahnsinnig genug heutzutage in Browsern.
Wir nehmen das ja alles auf, Max.
Sogar der iPhone-Browser hat Tabs.
In einem halben Jahr werden die Hörer über die Managed.
Ja, weil sie oben keine Tab-Leiste reinkriegen. Aber das sind doch Tabs.
Das sind keine Tabs.
Was sind das denn?
Die kommen ja von alleine. Also ich meine, bei den anderen muss ich es ja machen.
Wie die kommen von alleine?
Na ich mach ne neue Seite und der macht sozusagen ein neues Tab. Das ist unten mit dem Firecake, das ist beim normalen Safari. Passiert das aber nicht. Der macht höchstens ein neues Fenster auf, was ja dann kein neues Tab ist. Egal. Aber wir haben noch News und zwar...
Bei Safari kommen die auf dem iPhone genauso wenig allein wie sonst auch und auch an Safari gehen neue Fenster.
Gibt's Gerüchte, dass eine neue Maus kommt mit Touch-Dings? Das find ich interessant.
Ich wär schon mal froh, wenn sie endlich mal diese Computer ausliefern könnten, weil ich bin gerade in der einmaligen Situation. Ich will mir drei Macintoshes kaufen. Drei Stück?
Ja. Das ist wohl zu viel Geld, wa?
Nein, aber ich habe mir schon sehr, sehr lange keinen Macintosh mehr gekauft.
Was willst du denn holen? Einen Mac Mini, einen iMac und ein neues Macbook.
Ich brauch einen neuen Laptop, weil mein Macbook ist einfach mal drüber.
Deine Rechner sind immer drüber.
Ja, aber... Ich schlage mich so drüber wie das.
Du willst mal wieder eins mit weniger drüber.
Ich denke, ich werde wahrscheinlich einen 15 Zoll auf 15 Zoll gehen. Ich hab lange überlegt und ich tendiere jetzt dazu. Aber erstmal will ich meinen iMac...
Oder einen kleinen...
15 Zoll ist toll.
Das räumt sich auch auf 13 Zoll. Bitte?
Oder hier wieder ein kleines 13 Zoll für unterwegs, ganz nett, und dann hier ein Display hinstellen.
Ja, für unterwegs, da hab ich halt auch drüber überlegt, aber wenn ich unterwegs bin, dann fahre ich irgendwie mit dem Zug, mit viel Gepäck und da ist irgendwie der Unterschied zwischen 13 und 15 Zoll, fällt einfach überhaupt nicht mehr ins Gewicht. Und wenn ich auf leichtes Gepäck aus bin, dann habe ich eh keinen Computer dabei, dann habe ich einfach mein iPhone dabei. Das ist einfach, das iPhone hat es einfach geändert. Und der 13 Zoll hat keinen Digitaleingang, auch wenn es vielleicht nicht das Wichtigste ist auf diesem Planeten, aber... Ich habe halt von Leuten gehört, die einen 13 Zoll haben, das Ding atmet auch einfach zu viel. Das heißt, es wird bei CPU-Lass, bei hoher CPU-Lass zu schnell warm, kriegt sich irgendwie nicht so richtig entlüftet und dann Lüfter. Und wenn ich irgendwas hasse, dann sind es Lüfter. Und das wäre dann sozusagen der 15 Zoller, der ja dann eh eigentlich nicht so super mobil ist, wie er eigentlich ist. Mal gucken. Aber eigentlich will ich mein iMac kaufen und ich will mein Mac Mini kaufen.
Aber das nächste Macbook Pro hat ja dann vielleicht schon einen Quad?
Der nächste iMac sollte einen Quad haben und ich hoffe, dass das Scheißteil jetzt endlich mal rauskommt. Ich dachte ja gestern wär's soweit. Ich hatte schon einen bestellt. Die Dinger sind irgendwie nicht lieferbar. Das hat schon zwei Wochen gedauert. Dann habe ich meine Bestellung gecancelt, nachdem sie es nochmal um eine Woche verzögert haben. Also es hätte dann schon drei Wochen gedauert und ich habe jetzt keine Erkenntnis, ob mittlerweile vielleicht andere irgendwie geliefert wurden. Das war halt so Build to Order. Es kam einfach nichts und das höre ich einfach aus verschiedenen Quellen und irgendwie.
Soll ich mal zeige, für ein neuer Rechner, oder?
Oder für Nachschubprobleme. Aber es ist halt auch bei Mac Mini so und es ist irgendwie alles total unklar. Und dann halt noch diese Gerüchte, Lage, lalalala. Ich will nicht so viel über Gerüchte reden, weil das ist immer so müßig. Tatsache ist, wenn jetzt hier ein neuer Schubrechner announced wird, dann werde ich so viel Apple kaufen, wie ich in meinem Leben noch nicht gekauft habe.
Hast du das gehört, Steve?
Der Tim will Rechner kaufen.
Ja, aber ihr müsst iTunes fixen.
Neuschreiben, aufsplitten.
Genau.
Das mit dem Aufsplitten machen die nie.
So, genau.
Aber die neue Maus, seltsam davon.
Neue Maus, ach so, ohne Klitoris?
Wieder ohne Button jetzt, ganz ohne, sondern mit Touch.
Na und ohne?
Wenn es funktioniert, bitteschön.
Und ohne Infrarot, also ohne optischen Sensor. Wahrscheinlich über Beschleunigungssensoren. Aber es gibt ja...
Mit dem Finger willst du irgendwie Beschleunigungssensor?
Nein, mit dem Maus selbst. Da glaube ich ja nicht so dran.
Naja, das ist relativ, also ich meine, es gibt ja schon Bilder von der Unterseite der neuen Maus.
Ich kann die Maus so langsam bewegen, das kriegt ihr nie mit.
Was?
Spitzbar flich. Beschleunigungssensoren sind sehr, sehr auflösend.
Also es gibt Aufnahmen, es gibt Bilder von unten, also schematische Bilder, wo die ganzen Logos hinkommen. Und während man bei der alten Mighty Maus noch sieht, da muss der Sensor hin, ist da jetzt eine Latte von Logos und es ist einfach kein Platz mehr da für den Sensor. Bzw. für den Schienemechanismus. Und bei dem alten konnte man noch den Sensor sehen und beim neuen ist da einfach nichts. Aber insofern haben sie vermutlich irgendein System sich ausgedacht, um Beschleunigungssensoren. Das wäre natürlich in deinem Zug lustig, wenn du den ganzen Tag im Zug fährst und der ICE bremst ab und dein Maus-Cursor rutscht so ab und willst schon nach oben. Das ist ehrlich gesagt sowieso was, worauf ich schon seit Jahren warte, dass wenn ich im Zug bremse, so bei einer Folgerung so in eine Finster nach oben rutschen oder zur Seite fangen.
Stimmt. Das wär mal was.
Interesting. Ich würde mir jedenfalls so eine Maus besorgen, obwohl meiner, nachdem ich die wirklich auseinandergenommen hab, man muss die aufbrechen und ich hab mal die Kugel gesäubert. Geht die jetzt wieder, aber wenn die Kugel mal dreckig ist, ist das schon ganz schön nervig.
Du hast eine Maus mit Kugel?
Das ist doch dieses Kügelchen oben.
Ach, oben die Kugel.
Besser als ein Scrollwheel. Dieses Scrollwheel, die sind jetzt echt nicht mehr so modern. Dieses kleine Kügelchen, das ist echt geil. Vor allem dieses simulierte Klick, dass du echt denkst, du hast da so einen Widerstand dabei, kommt halt aus einem kleinen Klicker-Lautsprecher aus der Maus innen drin. Die Schumme ist echt hin, aber das Gehirn zählt so was drauf rein, dass ich weiß und sehe und du hast trotzdem mit dem Finger das Gefühl, dass da so ein Ruckelwiderstand ist.
Ja, aber ohne Scheiß, wenn du einmal hier mit diesem Glass-Trackpad bei dem Mac Pro gearbeitet hast, dann willst du nicht mehr irgendwie ein Scroll-Rädchen oder sowas. Das ist so dieses...
Da ist ja auch Glas drauf. Das ist ja die Maus aus Glas.
Vielleicht ist es die Maus aus Glas. Endlich noch was, wenn du es runterfallen lässt.
Ich kann mit einer Maus schneller Point-and-Shoot machen auf dem Bildschirm.
Also das geht, ich kann sehr schnell wechseln zwischen Maus, Trackpad und Tastatur.
Ohne Frage, das ist auf jeden Fall der Fall.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es schneller geht, aber was ich total toll finde, ist so in Firefox Taps wechseln, mit drei Finger Drag vor und zurück gehen, mit Finger links und rechts.
Du kannst eine Maus haben und die andere Hand auf den Touch, das ist ja kein Problem.
Es sind einfach schöne Gesten, gerade zum Beispiel in Tweety unterstützt ein paar Gesten. Und das ist großartig, das will man nicht mehr missen. Also wenn die neue Maus das dann auch hat, dass man da auch noch irgendwie zwei und drei Finger Gesten hinkriegt, bin ich ja mal sehr gespannt darauf.
Das wäre total cool. Und dann ist auch der Zeitpunkt, wo Apple dann wirklich die Scrollbars auch wieder verschwinden lassen kann, indem sie es genauso machen wie auf dem iPhone, weil du wirklich nur mit dem Finger so lang ziehst. Wie oft wollte ich schon in Twitterriffig mit dem Finger scrollen, weil es schon so nach iPhone aussieht?
Das wäre endlich mal fett.
Nee, ich muss mit der Maus dahin, das ist mir schon ganz oft passiert.
Die Abschaffung des Rollbalkens. Das ist ein Apple, das ist mal wieder was, was man machen könnte.
Das ist mir auch beim Benutzung von dem Android aufgefallen, wenn man da scrollt und man kommt unten an, dann bleibt es einfach so stehen. Beim iPhone ist es ja, du scrollst ja ein Stück über den Rand hinaus, dann siehst du, dass da nichts ist, sozusagen das Ende des Universums, und dann scrollt, dann sprengt er sozusagen wieder ein Stück zurück.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Also du scrollst, du scrollst bis zum Ende, dann stößt er an, dann gehst du ein Stück drüber hinaus, federt so ein bisschen über den Rand, und federt dann wieder zurück bis zum Ende. Und das ist beim Android nicht, der stößt einfach nur an. Das ist echt vom Gefühl her so, stößt er an, und das ist so unnatürlich, dieses so ein bisschen drüber und wieder zurück, das fühlt sich echt an wie, wie es halt überall so ist.
Ich glaube, dass er es mal bei Macintosh einzuhält.
Das ist nämlich eine total schicke Sache, da haben die echt mal wieder richtig nachgedacht.
Das kann die Welt gerade gar nicht hören, weil der Stream weg ist. Ja, ja, ja, aber ich wollte es unaufwendig einfließen lassen, der Stream ist weg.
Okay, also ich habe jetzt eine Schnauze voll, mir fällt nichts mehr ein. Ja, also nicht so richtig in letzter Zeit, was noch neu war.
Ich bin einfach zu müde jetzt. Nächstes Mal. Dann haben wir wieder frische Themen und haben alles immer abgearbeitet, was weg ist.
Noch ein kleiner ZFS-Hit. Man soll noch von Fletcher 2 auf Fletcher 4 umstellen, weil Fletcher 2 haben sie beschissen implementiert. Und die Erkennungsrate ist nicht so hoch bei Fletcher 4. Der schecksamen Algorithmus, den sie da benutzen, um zu erkennen, ob ein Block kaputt ist. Und die haben den Scheiß implementiert. Das könnte sein, dass der nicht so gut erkennt, dass ein Block kaputt ist. Deswegen sollen wir zu Fletcher 4 wechseln.
Guck an, hast du da ein komplett neues Layout?
Du kannst den On-the-Fly einfach wechseln. In alten Daten sind zwar noch mit Fletcher 2, aber alles, was neu geschrieben wird, wird auf jeden Fall schon mal mit Fletcher 4 geschrieben.
Fletcher, Fletcher, Fletcher.
Jep, haben sie.
Und in Freebies, der ist das jetzt so richtig drin? ZFS mit Release und Trellada. Version 9. Acht.
Acht. Neun hat gerade angefangen, neun Current. Und acht null sind sie bei Release Candidate 1 oder vielleicht schon zwei, weiß ich nicht genau. Und kommt demnächst raus und da ist dann ZFS mit dabei. Und da steht nichts mehr von Beta und so weiter, sondern es ist schon...
Das kann richtig davon booten. Und es gibt nur ZFS.
Kann davon booten und ja.
Das ist einfach fast class Fallsystem.
Geil. Das hab ich ja schon zu Hause so. Ich boot von einem ZFS-Mirror direkt ohne irgendeine andere Partition dazwischen.
Tja, jetzt müsste man sich das noch auf so eine komische SATA-Enclosure draufballern, wo so ein PC mit irgendwie Festplatten drin ist und dann...
Gibt's wohl irgendwie dieses Frienlast oder wie auch immer?
Als Software. Ich rede davon nach. Achso, ist Fri-Last Fri-BSD?
Das ist halt irgendein Tool, was auf irgendeine Kiste draufklatscht und da hast du dann einmal so alles. Ich glaube, die unterstützen jetzt auch schon. ZFS bin mir nicht ganz so sicher.
Na, das wäre so die Voraussetzung.
Naja, ich denke aber schon.
Leute, ich fall tot vorm Stuhl.
Du bist schon tot vorm Stuhl gefallen.
Ich bin dabei tot vorm Stuhl zu sein.
Die fragen ja alle ZFS auf Mac. Ne, ne, das war jetzt gerade alles ZFS on FreeBSD.
Genau, auf Mac gibt es leider noch nichts Gutes zu berichten. So, gute Nachrichten dann wieder nächstes Mal bei Mobile Macs 0.30.
Jetzt hängt es hier noch schön in unserer.
Ja, das war glaube ich nicht auf der Aufnahme drauf, aber leider gibt es in diesem Studio kein OMTS. Deswegen müssen wir eigentlich alle unsere Telefon aussteigen. Und das war's.
Das war's?
Bis bald.
Dann hat das Telefon jetzt quasi Tschüss gesagt. Tschüss.
Yup, hat sie wahrscheinlich abgemeldet.